This is Jocko podcast number one 68 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Beowulf spoke.
Why Sir do not grieve.
It is always better to avenge dear ones than to indulge in mourning.
For every one of us.
Living in this world means waiting for our end.
Let whoever can win glory before death.
When a warrior is gone,
that will be his best and only bowl work.
So arise my lord and let us immediately set forth on the trail of this troll
dam.
I guarantee you,
she will not get away not to dens underground nor upland groves,
nor the ocean floor.
She'll have nowhere to fleet to and dirty your troubles today.
Bear up and be the man I expect you to be.
There is some more Beowulf to start this podcast and it's an interesting note
that Beowulf,
the poem started not as a written poem,
but a poem passed on as a story from generation to generation of the Pagan Anglo
Saxon Warrior people.
It was part of their oral history in their oral tradition and that's basically
what we're doing here.
Capturing stories from our modern day warrior people,
which we are continuing with today during part two of my brother Jason Gardner.
Part one was the last podcast number one 67 so if you haven't listened to that
one,
just stop listening to this one right now.
Go back and listen to one 67 and then when you get done with that you can come
back and hear the rest of it.
And if you have listened to 61 67 when here we go.
We're going to start kind of where we left off.
What's up Jason?
Now much happy to be here.
Check.
So we left off yesterday.
You had basically you'd stayed at team three you're going to an ops tour,
an ops task unit,
ops tour,
but then you made senior chief and then that's where we left off.
So you get done with that and where'd you go seal things happen.
The one over to the senior enlisted academy and knock that out because that is
basically a prerequisite for making ie nine but it's difficult to get away from
NSW for that long course.
That one was six weeks.
There's two of them,
there's another one that's three months and it's just trying to cram that in.
It is difficult.
So it made sense to go then and then they,
they pop me over
for a,
uh,
a troop,
senior enlisted advisor over its seal team seven.
And so for people that don't know what that means,
you're going into a task unit,
your task,
would you,
did you guys have a two platoon task unit or was it it was to check and that
means explain your position of senior enlisted advisor in a sealed tasking it.
So there are two seal platoons,
which are the two maneuver elements.
And then over the top of the seal platoons,
there's myself,
I was a senior chief at the time and then there was a,
uh,
a lieutenant commander at the time it was the,
the task unit commander.
It was the same position that you had in a tea brews.
Yup.
And then you were the senior enlisted guy in there.
And I was actually looking at one of my old briefs leadership briefs from the
teams.
I don't know if you remember this cause I haven't,
I don't do it when I do it for civilians now.
But I used to do the roles and responsibilities of everyone inside the the task
unit and be like,
okay,
this is what the task and the commanders and should be doing.
This is what the senior enlisted guy should be doing.
And a keyword there is this sort of platoon chief should be doing and this is
what a platoon commander should be doing.
One of the key words there is,
should be,
because there's a lot of leeway depending on personalities and what skill sets
people have.
And sometimes people are capable of doing a part of someone else's job but
they're maybe not so great at doing something they should be doing.
So you gotta figure that out inside of a platoon.
Now,
I used to say that when you take a platoon,
if you take a platoon,
you've got to get to,
like,
you could pick a number,
like you've got to get to a level 10 with the top four leadership,
meaning the Lpo,
the assistant platoon commander of the platoon commander.
And the platoon chief,
those,
they have to have a number equal to 10.
Like you can't have a bunch of guys that are ones,
cause that's only a four,
but you,
if you have a chief that's an eight,
well then cool.
It's like,
doesn't really matter that the platoon commander is not that great or the
platoon commanders a wand or whatever.
Um,
and,
and that's fine.
Sometimes you're going to get some guys that are really good at something.
Sometimes there's people that aren't.
And as long as you have some good leadership in there,
you'll be all right.
And that's what I realized when I was running trade it,
you just basically need,
you need one leader,
one person that knows how to lead things and everything will be fine.
You,
but you actually should have two people that know how to lead things.
So that way if something happens to the number one guy and then they can kind of
communicate and they can talk to each other and they can bounce stuff off and
they'll just be like infinitely better.
Um,
but yeah,
it's uh,
it's always a little bit different in every task unit and well that was great
because that roles and responsibilities brief that you gave at the time,
the tea,
you tasking your leadership going through the unit level training was,
was new and it was kind of a new position all the way together.
So it wasn't really well defined.
I was really like where the hell is my role here?
Um,
so that,
that was really helpful.
And I think what you and your troop sea did is you kind of define,
cause you guys participated in training and not all
the troops,
troop commanders in troop sea days,
we're going out to every you lt block.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I didn't know you guys did everything and then after that that was the standard.
Everybody set that standard and it's a good standard to have.
Yeah.
And I was lucky cause my first deployment to Iraq I had a task unit commander
and in a task unit sea.
And we both are friends with both of those guys and they really,
like I was watching what they were doing going,
okay,
that seems to work pretty well.
You know,
just looking at how they interacted with me and they set a good example.
And I kinda just took that when I came back.
And,
and that's the position I put myself into was kind of mimicking what those two
guys had done.
And they bet were really well balanced,
you know,
not micro and they're just this guilt,
just really good leaders,
you know?
And so I just,
okay,
that was cool.
That worked.
And so that's what I did.
And then luckily I got to go through workup and then go to Ramadi.
So I kind of knew how it,
you know,
I,
I carved that out and they're there.
It was,
and then I wrote the rules and responsibilities because believe me,
when I was,
when I first took over trade,
that there would be all kinds of ways waylay things going on with guys and not
having any idea of what they should and should not be doing because they were,
everyone was just going,
what should I do?
Like you said,
it was a new position,
a relatively new position.
I mean,
we had tasking to commanders back in the day,
but it was,
they would be completely detached in and they'd show up,
hey,
I'm an o three or no,
four,
I'm in charge of you and everyone to be a little good.
That sounds cool.
Whatever.
Who's this guy?
Yeah.
And you wouldn't see him until deployment.
And then now,
now the new thing was,
are you like there from day one,
which was really cool.
How we evolve that way.
Yeah.
No,
and it's,
it's as it should be.
So you get there and form up your platoons and start going through training.
You start doing work up.
And so,
you know,
uh,
the task unit commander,
he had a lot of experience.
The both the,
all the platoon leadership had a lot of experience too.
So it was,
it was,
I would say it was stacked.
We had great all the way down to like some of our [inaudible] had deployments to
Iraq.
They had good experience.
So it looked like,
you know,
hey,
this is,
everything's going to be easy.
Um,
and then we started,
started you lt,
uh,
went out to the land warfare block,
which is really always been where I have a soft spot in my heart because it's,
it's hard,
it's dirty and it's mean.
But,
uh,
you know,
we train out there in the desert.
We were,
we'd gone through the first two weeks of the land warfare block,
which is doing our immediate action drills,
a lot of our range work,
our demo,
all that stuff.
And then we were coming into the phase the last week,
which is the field final training exercises.
And so we're,
we're in this big classroom and we're getting the brief on,
you know,
uh,
feedback on,
on the brief that we've just given for our first operation.
And after that,
the,
your,
your land warfare senior enlisted advisor came in,
he's like,
hey everybody,
listen up every task unit that's come through here before you guys has had a
blue on blue during this training.
So you need to be really aware of your blue pours picture.
And,
and so,
well,
I'm like,
I'm rolling my eyes and my internal dialogue is,
oh my gosh,
what a bunch of clowns are you kidding me?
Everybody's shot each other.
That is never going to happen to us.
You know,
I'm like,
heck,
I used to run land warfare training when I was at,
at a training sell at a team and this just isn't that hard.
There's no way we're going to shoot each other.
Okay.
Like,
let's just go four hours later.
It is just mass pandemonium.
We've,
we went in,
we hit a target,
things kind of were going really smooth and then all of a sudden everything fell
apart.
We were,
we had like,
I think we had seven down guys that we were tracking and then,
but that we couldn't even get clear word because everybody was talking on the
radio at the same time.
We're trying to break off the target.
There was no organization,
there were guys all over the high ground around us.
I remember real specifically one of the fire teams pointing up to a mountain
that was just to our left saying,
Hey,
do we have friendly's up there?
And someone else saying,
no,
we don't have anybody.
You know,
and looking at a battle now,
no,
we don't have anybody up there.
And then that fire team wiped out what was our sniper element.
So we had a whole fire team just wipe out,
uh,
you know,
our Forman sniper element trying to come down high ground when the down man of
their own
and in,
so we,
we made it to the extract a dragon,
all our bodies out of order,
everybody talking,
get back to the camp,
realize we're missing a piece of sensitive equipment.
Um,
and then in the debrief we discover that we'd had this heinous blue on blue and
you know,
a fire team.
It pretty much wiped out another fire team and we're just like,
oh man.
So we pushed guys back out to the field to find a gear that we'd lost and thank
goodness they found it before we get to stop training to,
to find that gear.
Um,
and then,
you know,
we,
we did by no fault of my own,
we did a really healthy assessment of what you guys as the training attachment
had put us through.
And instead of going,
Whoa,
you know,
blaming,
you guys are making excuses are like,
okay,
let's make a list.
And we knocked out like four things that we messed up the worst for things that
we messed up and then how we were going to fix them.
Like,
okay,
well this down man thing,
we don't have it.
Right.
We better start caring and stretchers in the field.
Um,
and then we're going to stick,
each fire team is going to have a pair of bag.
So when a guy gets killed,
we're taking all the sensitive stuff off of him so we can move them easy.
We put them in the pair bag so we don't lose it.
Okay,
that's done.
Alright.
Um,
guys,
we get,
everyone's got to stop talking on the radio at the same time.
We got to get some comms disciplines.
We ran some drills.
Uh,
we ran drills on how we were going to get head counts.
Um,
and you know,
then we,
then we did the drills on how are we going to identify each other in the dark as
soon as their bullets without,
you know,
with no coms.
And,
uh,
and so we laid that out and like,
hey everybody,
here's where,
you know,
carry the,
the BS 17 panel.
It's like everyone's going to have that in your left shoulder pocket,
the little three foot ones down.
So that's during daytime.
At nighttime we're going to use our strobes.
And,
uh,
well,
you know,
they're at the time and even today,
I'll tell you what,
if I was going out today and I was worried about the enemy having night vision,
I would be more worried about,
and this is me personally,
and I don't want to argue this with anybody and you can hit me up about my own
guys shooting me because they can shoot and they have big guns.
Then the enemy's seeing my strobe.
So that,
that was something that panned out later.
So we did that.
I thought we did it in a real healthy way.
We,
we Kinda,
we were really cutting corners with our rehearsals because we don't get graded
on a rehearsals.
We get graded on a brief.
So all the effort goes into the brief,
but the brief doesn't stick with you mentally until you go out and rehearse it.
And so we're like,
hey,
here's the way we're going to do are,
uh,
you know,
our head counts and,
and we,
we would do head counts by fire team.
Someone would say headcount and then fire team six is up,
five's up for up threes,
up two's up,
one's up like okay we go out,
rehearse it and we get to fire team three and the guy would be spacing it and
we're like hey fire team three and okay and we get to the point where that was
just second nature.
And then to the point where everybody,
cause we got decentralized command going on now when we're moving off target
sit,
fire team,
six nos,
a headcount is coming and they just kick it off and it just rolls through and
there's,
there's no issues.
So we got that done,
we did our Nascar next FTX we did considerably better but you guys ramped up the
pressure and then we had other issues and we're like okay hey when we get all
mixed up we got to be able to reorganize without sounding like a high school
cafeteria.
So then I think the next thing we punched into us,
our reorg perimeters in the dark and we would go out and just mix everybody up
and I go boom,
someone won't pass this.
The hand signal for perimeter and then we would go get it and get reorg and uh,
and he ended up like that.
And,
and,
and what I've really enjoyed about the training,
and I told people who came through it later was that it was,
it was like,
it was super challenging and it was like,
it was like going to a haunted house and,
and like I enjoy going to haunted houses because I like to go through and
something startles me and I'm not really happy that something like a guy popping
out with a chainsaw or whatever startles me.
And so I'll go through it,
then I'll assess how I reacted and I'll go next time,
let's do something new.
But it's completely new and unexpected and you guys continued to turn that dial
up of completely new and unexpected and that panned out to work out so well for
us because we had the right attitude about it.
And later on when I'm moving in that position,
when you talk about that later,
I could see a healthy way to deal with that and the not healthy way to deal with
it in a healthy way is all was owning it and taking responsibility and then it
just,
it was so much fun.
I just be,
we'd be done,
we'd be covering sweat,
everybody was yelling and uh,
um,
was a great experience.
And then we just,
we took that and then the other blocks of training and,
and the,
the most intense for leadership is definitely land warfare.
And then south,
which is our urban training and we just got hammered there too.
And then it's paint ball and a,
a bunch of other stuff.
But uh,
that was great.
One other thing,
like when you did your roles and responsibilities,
you didn't really define a position for the,
the troops senior enlisted advisor because in that you're still like,
hey,
you're not really going to be the,
the assault lead or anything else like that.
Because honestly like you've said,
yeah,
the thing was could run in a song.
The thing I used to say is,
is the senior enlisted advisor is the action arm for the task unit commander.
So there's going to be things that are going to be need to make be made happen
and that's the guy that's going to make it happen.
So,
oh we got a building that's got a problem or we got to a position that's needs
support or we get a wounded guy like in the army and the Marine Corps,
their sop is it who runs a Casio Vac?
It's the senior enlisted guy.
Cause that's the guy that goes,
oh he has the experience to make this happen under a massively stressful
situation.
So my word to the senior list of guys were like,
you're the action arm.
This the task unit commander can't make things happen.
He,
he's got to,
he's got to look at what else is going on and he's got to figure out what the
next step is going to be.
He's talking,
getting information,
he's passing information.
All that stuff is going to,
he can't take time to go clear an extra building or set up a security perimeter
on this.
Rich talked like he can't do that.
That's the senior enlisted guy that goes,
hey boss.
And obviously he's saying,
hey boss,
if if you want to get out of here,
here's what I'm going to make happen.
I'm going to go set up a perimeter over here.
I'm gonna put gunner's up on that high ground.
And then you guys can peel through here and that's where we'll leave.
And the tea,
you commander goes awesome.
Yes.
Execute.
So that's,
that to me has always been the best way to utilize the senior enlisted because
if you put the senior enlisted actually in charge of something,
but guess what they're doing,
they're doing that thing and then when something else goes sideways,
who's,
who's going to handle that now?
And it always seems to happen in a seam.
Yeah.
So it's like the most complicated thing to,
right.
The thing that's hard to handle is the thing that you didn't plan for.
And so if you don't have,
it's just like,
it's just like you don't want to commit your reserves,
right?
You don't want to commit your reserves in,
in a situation where you don't have to.
We don't want it as a tea.
You commander,
you have one guy as like the reserve that you have reserved brainpower and your
reserve brainpower is your is your SCA because if something goes wrong you can't
get on it,
but you need the most experienced tactically savvy guy to go and handle whatever
it is,
which you may not even know how to handle,
but you just know that you've got,
you know,
enemy approaching on a road from the north,
you're getting intel,
you're,
you're getting fed information.
Hey,
there's enemy approaching on the note road from the north,
a senior get it taken care of.
And then senior goes,
I got it.
And it goes and handles it.
And,
and that's basically how we execute it.
And what was it,
what's really interesting is that overcomes and guys would,
and comms would be up and a lot of times comms go down but overcomes the word
would be like,
hey,
we're leaving breakdown your security.
And then you're waiting for a call and waiting for a call and waiting for a
call.
And then,
you know,
I'd have to run over there and say it,
looking at someone actually say it and then they're like,
oh.
And for some reason they're there,
they're hearing it in their headset and uh,
um,
it,
it just,
it ain't happening and you just got to go guys get,
they get jammed up,
you know,
and that hourglass is just turning and turning and turning and you got to go
back,
you know,
hit him to get things moving at that process or moving and going again.
And then sometimes just your presence there and what,
you know,
talking about yelling,
you're not yelling at them,
but like,
hey,
boom,
get the 60 gunner down.
Let's go.
Yep,
we're moving this way.
Hey,
get that wounded man over there.
The strategy,
ditch the stretcher,
we're done.
Go.
And then hustling everybody up and just trying to keep everything moving around.
And I'll say this now,
everything that we faced in combat
was easier than the stuff we faced in training because you'd put the screws on
us so hard that we were like,
oh,
okay,
we've seen something pretty Dang close to this before.
So when when a guy stepped on a,
on an ID and lost his legs that we didn't experience and training,
but everybody dealt with it in a professional way in a course that was a
horrible situation.
But that was not something that we were new to.
We were like,
Oh,
okay,
we've done it down men,
we've,
we've had this situation,
you already had a couple of guys get pretty severely wounded.
Um,
and it was,
it was a factor in their pain,
but it was no factor in how we fought and,
and how we dealt with the situation.
Uh,
there were there a couple of times that we came ludicrously close to blue on
blues,
but because we had,
we had,
you'd reinforced everything and training because we mitigated those blue and
blue's bloodlessly in training.
We didn't have them on the battlefield.
Yeah,
well it was,
I mean for me coming into that role coming home,
I was,
I was pretty emotionally connected to the fact that I wanted you guys to be
ready and just,
you know,
like the whole down down man thing.
Like,
it's not easy to carry it down,
man.
Especially not easy when the guy helps you and he kind of,
it's in training and he kind of jumps up on your shoulder and puts his hand in
that right spot on your back to stabilize himself and all those little things
that they do to help each other out.
It's like,
it's not that easy.
It sucks.
And the blue on blue thing,
and I remember I a task unit,
you're tasking and included would have a blue on blue and I'd bring them into
the office and everyone in the chain of command would sign like a safety
violation.
And,
and I would tell everyone,
I'd say,
listen,
I'm not doing this degrading you because they'll person in this room that's had
a real blue on blue where people got killed is me and I,
the one thing I don't want is for it to happen to you.
So there's so much,
uh,
driving me just to,
to,
to try and make it as realistic as possible.
And then,
you know,
you get the kick ass team guys that are running all the training.
Once you give those guys that direction,
they're just going to go.
And that's just,
you know,
so I mean,
I'd show up for the training sites and the guys would be so amped to make the
training awesome.
And you know,
the amount of effort that,
the amount of effort that guys would put in to make the training realistic was
crazy.
I mean,
some of those out at land warfare,
some of the demolitions that would get set up,
they would take him three,
four days.
They'd stay out on the training on a site for three or four days,
setting demo up everywhere.
So there's stuff blowing up and catching on fire and just smoke everywhere.
Total,
total mayhem.
And you know,
there's,
there's only,
this is the,
when you're training,
there's only so much you can do to simulate combat because what you can't do,
there's a line that you cannot cross.
You can't shoot people,
you can't do it.
You can't wound your men in training.
And so that line can never get crossed.
And so what can you do to get it as close to that line as possible?
And the the laser system that we had and the explosives and then all just
unleashing all that chaos and mayhem and I was lucky that I got to experience
that on the battlefield and come home and be like,
Bro.
And you know you mentioned it quickly like your attitude towards it,
but your attitude towards it is what the winning task unit attitude always was
because it's really easy to go through those bullshit.
You had a bunch of good sit up on that hill like yeah and you don't think
alcaide is going to set people up on a hill.
You don't think the movie is going to set people in a spider hole in the middle
of a compound.
You don't think,
by the way,
all that stuff,
we got it from actual after actions reports.
So the fact that you and your,
your task unit instead of looking at everyone else as to why you didn't do a
good job,
you looked at yourself and said,
okay,
well can we actually do better?
How about we actually try and improve some things?
How about we pick three,
four things.
We try and do those things better and then you do those things better and you're
right because,
and you know this from working in training your,
you already know what's going to happen.
Like you can see you,
you put a guy here,
you put a bad guy over here,
you put a bad guy over there,
you've got a terrain feature like this.
You know what's going to happen and you watch it unfold.
And then you also know that if the leadership can make some good calls,
it's going to be no factor.
If the,
if the platoons have good standard operating procedures,
it'll be no factor.
But if they're not and the leadership starts to fall apart,
I mean everything falls apart.
And that thing you just said about the firearm,
I used to tell the task and Krannert says,
I used to say,
imagine you got,
you got your fire teams out there.
Imagine if each one of your fire teams was doing something good that was moving
you in the direction that you wanted them to move.
Just imagine if that happened.
And what happens when that occurs is the leader doesn't actually have to say
barely anything other than we're getting out of here.
And as soon as everyone,
we're heading south,
we're getting out of here,
going to our old rally point.
As soon as everyone knows that they just make it happen and do you commander can
do whatever he wants to do because the fire team leaders are going to make
things happen themselves.
And,
and w and the opposite of that is there's no possible way you can control all
these people if you have to tell them everything that you want him to do.
You can't say,
hey,
you can't talk to all those people.
At the same time,
you can't know what the vantage point,
the best vantage point for us to 60 gunner is going to be on that little note.
You can't do it.
That guy has to understand what it is that is wanted from him and why it's
important for him to do it.
And then once he knows that he makes it happen.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
I think it was my tea,
you commander that you're talking about when you do,
you said that you didn't initially,
you weren't sure if quiet guys could lead because he wasn't,
he's not allowed God,
like I'm a allowed God.
Yeah,
he's,
his personality is,
is,
is different.
He's not super loud,
but he was direct,
clear and concise.
And he did a fantastic,
I really enjoyed working with him.
And he's a good example of that.
I mean,
he's,
he's not the guy specifically I'm talking about,
but he's a guy that was,
you know,
especially like the little things you were just barking out.
Put a 60 over there,
get put that stretcher away.
We're leaving it,
get that wound,
admit those things.
If you're not loud,
it's it.
They just don't get hurt.
And so with your task unit commander,
I noticed that and was kind of like,
hey man,
you know,
you need to get louder.
And,
and what he did was this,
you know,
get,
Hey,
you know,
he's pretty loud.
My stupid sta standing over and all those,
those tattoos on his arm.
He might not be the smartest dude in the world,
but he's loud.
And when he tells you,
hey,
tell him to put that stretch away,
whatever,
then you or whoever in your in your task and starts barking out the orders and
it happens,
you know?
And so yeah,
he did.
He did a great job of that and had the same attitude as you cause he was
experienced.
You know,
that was another cool thing,
you know,
you'd get,
I'd get guys that were coming through training more experience than me and the
good seal leaders would come through that training,
be like,
oh that was awesome man.
Yeah,
you just kicked our ass.
Thank you.
We're going to try and do better.
What did you see?
Like they would just want feedback,
just want suggestions and then you'd get other guys coming through that it was
everyone else's fault and the training wasn't really with no realistic to get
hit from three sides really.
Is that,
where do you see that in the Geneva Convention?
That you're not allowed to ambush from three sides.
And that attitude never turned out well.
It just never,
it zero 0% of turning out well of,
hey the training is unrealistic.
The training is this,
the training is at like no actually just do the sop step up and lead and
everything works.
And that was the other amazing thing is you'd see the same problems and once uh,
once a tasking that got good [inaudible] you couldn't even stop him cause it's,
cause it's 40 guys against four or five.
As you know,
the training that's training guys are,
it's like four or five guys out there shooting them up.
So yeah,
I mean when you're running those scenarios,
you can't bring your guys back to life,
which you can remotely do fast enough to apply a decent amount of pressure to
win.
That troop has just gotten up on steel and then then everybody is so happy.
Yeah.
You can't,
you're right.
You can't reset people.
You can't reset the op for quick enough because the,
because the,
when you get a seal troop that's just in straight of aggressive merger mode and
going hard,
every little thing they see,
they're assaulting.
It's awesome.
It's a beautiful thing to see.
So,
um,
now when you,
you guys,
were you guys planning to go to Afghanistan knowing that workup?
I don't think you were right.
Where are you?
We were slated to go to Bosnia and so we were going to be going down to southern
Iraq and a working out of there.
And then the request for forces popped up that they were asking for a seal troop
back in Afghanistan.
And I think
yeah,
on the,
on the numbered seal teams had been out of Afghanistan since somewhere around
2005.
So they,
there had been no presence whatsoever for a number of seal teams and Afghanistan
in a while.
This is a 2009.
So initially there was a,
it popped up and then,
then it was confirmed and then like over the Christmas holiday they said,
okay,
hey,
we're going to send that my troop is going to be the trip to Afghanistan.
What that looked like,
no one knew.
Is that what you're going to Afghanistan because there's a deployment order that
has to get signed to go anywhere.
That's got to be signed by the secretary of defense.
Right.
And ours to deploy a troop to a sealed troops to Afghanistan was in the book.
It hadn't been signed yet.
And so myself,
the task unit commander and one of the oics who deployed with you?
We did a pre deployment site survey and uh,
you know,
I think it was like in February we went,
oh.
And usually on a PD predeployment site survey or pre pdss you go over,
you see what's going on,
then you come back.
We went over there and I stayed in a CV.
Chief came with me who was,
uh,
who was going to set up our birding and stuff was one of our support or,
or all four of us went.
And then he and I never came back from that predeployment site survey.
We just stayed there.
So
yeah,
so going into,
you know,
in an awkward situation where we're,
we're going over there,
they were working for the army,
um,
SF and they don't even know what they're going to do with us.
A lot of them didn't want us because they'd had bad experiences.
Unfortunately,
it was seals before.
And so what I did was I kind of tore a page out of your book.
I didn't know this is what you guys did,
but this is what I did is I usually wear my hair like this.
I went ahead and got high and tight to shift over to look a little bit more.
Um,
well,
like the army does because it's just a,
it's just another way to establish rapport.
And I don't care about my hair.
I don't.
Um,
and,
and so,
so when we got there,
the first place we went was to,
to the CG soda if,
which is the,
uh,
the o six that's running everything there.
And I went into the sergeant major's office was the senior enlisted advisor.
I went in his office and stood at a time,
I introduced myself and stood at parade rest and he looked up from his desk and
stared at me.
Um,
and you know,
like I got a clean uniform on,
I got a high end,
tight end.
He goes,
I have never seen a cliq before.
And I kept it real professional with him.
And then he's like,
hey,
we don't know where we're going to put you.
We don't know what we're going to do with you guys.
We're working through that.
Um,
you guys have got to go ahead and brief the colonel at the time.
So we worked up a brief for the colonel on my task unit commander went in and,
uh,
had a meeting with them and he was,
he's a pretty fired up type of guy.
Um,
and he asked,
he asked the tea,
you commander like,
Hey,
what do you,
what do you need?
What do you need from me?
And uh,
the boss told him,
Hey,
we need the SEC def to sign,
sign our line item to get us to deploy here.
And a week later that happened,
legit and eat.
So it's in order where the SEC def is supposed to sign stuff and ours was like
ninth back and he went straight to our line item and signed it.
So that colonel,
we made a good impression on him.
He had some pull obviously and uh,
made an impression,
um,
moving forward.
So then we were looking at,
well,
okay,
where are we going to go?
We still didn't know where we were going to go.
Um,
and,
and we talked to the,
the,
we had a briefing with the general and he explained,
Hey,
I don't have enough partner forces for all of my,
uh,
you know,
Sfo,
da teams that are here because normally we're working by with and through.
And he goes,
so you guys are going to go on whatever con op is hot and plus up my ODH you are
going to attrite the Taliban and deny them freedom of movement.
I thought,
Hallelujah.
Yeah,
it doesn't get any better than that.
It doesn't.
And then we uh,
we moved down to Camp Brown.
Um,
and a third group was running the Special Operations Task Force West down there.
And we got there and I met with the senior enlisted advisor there and he's like,
hey,
we really don't,
we don't know where we're going to put you guys.
We don't have any space for you here.
And we just stayed good,
you know,
and,
and we established a relationship with him and this,
the,
the commander there and the Xo and the ops guys.
And then two days later they're,
the,
the sergeant major takes me out and he's like,
Hey,
you see this big tank,
this,
this is,
they had this big tent right inside the gate.
And he goes,
this is where we were doing all our vehicle maintenance.
we're getting ready to move those guys over to another yard.
You guys can have this.
And so,
so that was awesome.
We were basically like initially where we were the unwanted,
um,
you know,
in law showing up for Christmas,
like Randy Quaid and Christmas story.
And then now we were like,
Hey,
old college buddies that had come into town.
And third group was just so good to us.
There was absolutely no parochialism whatsoever and that was just a great
experience working with them across the board.
So how did you,
when did you start putting together,
how did you say,
okay,
this is what we're going to do?
How'd that come about with they just,
they just told us there's like,
here's what,
here's,
here's what we laid out,
here's our capabilities.
And there was like,
well,
here's how we'd like to use it.
And we said,
Roger,
that where can we help?
We never came in and said,
hey,
this is,
you know,
this is what we do when we come in and do this x,
y,
and Z.
Because they're targeting in their whole,
their whole philosophy was completely different than what they did in Iraq.
In Iraq,
we were very personality based and NSW as a whole,
we were were reduced to personality based talk targeting.
They're more about disruption.
They'd be like,
Hey,
Talibans over here in freedom movement.
We're going to go do stuff over there and then they're going to have to come
find us and then it's going to slow them down,
you know,
everywhere they're going.
Or Hey,
um,
they're funding this war with opium.
So are we going to burn down opium fields and punish the farmer?
Or do we wait till the Taliban collects the opium up into one spot and then go
destroy it?
And that's the kind of stuff that,
that we would do.
We would go to the opium cassez after the poor farmer who doesn't have a choice
about what he's growing is harvested,
that they moved it to one spot and then we pop in,
destroy all their opium,
stay there for,
for a couple of days and fight them and then leave.
So,
so that was good,
but our attitude was like,
how can we help?
Where can we help you?
And there they just gave us work and it was great.
And you guys had some pretty crazy ops.
Yeah,
I would say like,
so,
so the first op we had to add von crew that was there and we went out with a,
um,
uh,
three,
one,
one six in there commandos,
and they had an op where they went in and,
and took a,
uh,
a bizarre,
which is like a strip mall basically where they facilitated a bunch of opium,
went in,
held that,
destroyed all the opium for a day and then fought everybody that came at us.
So we went out on that operation with them and,
uh,
it was good.
It was a lot of fun.
Um,
and,
and then that got them used to us and,
and what we brought to the table,
and that was an op that was setting up in a concept of operations called see Jen
Jen.
And that was like the,
I think the first frag order under it.
And they would do a concept operation like,
hey,
here's what we want to do with this stuff.
And this is CJ engine was basically hammering the opium in the Helmand river
valley.
And it culminated with the last frag order and was when we went into Helmand in,
or we went to Hellman into Marcia,
which is like at the heart of the Taliban.
It was a Taliban controlled town.
Coalition forces had never been inside of it.
In a year later,
it was 2010 or 11 the marines went in there and cleared it and it was a huge
fire,
huge firefight prior to us going in there,
this operation.
And it was,
why when I say we,
it was us,
the Afghan commandos,
the NSF,
Oda and the OIB above them.
I think that gets Oeb,
right?
Yup.
So that detachment above them and we just plus them up and they're,
they're only be commander was equal rank to our task unit commander rank.
But like my boss was just like,
he didn't push back.
He was like,
Hey,
what do you need me to do?
And that,
that,
oh,
we be commander really appreciated that relationship that he didn't have to,
you know,
bump heads,
ego battle over.
I wouldn't be in this position.
Exactly.
Or I want to make this call.
So
coalition forces have never been inside of Marcia.
They'd tried to go close to us and just gotten shot out.
We choppered into a bizarre,
which was,
we took for the corner four blocks and a like a pretty huge area where there was
a ridiculous amount of opium consolidate it.
They were refining opium into heroin,
um,
and make an IED,
improvised explosive devices,
all kinds of stuff there in the middle of their town.
We went in there at night,
we stayed there for four days and just,
just got after it wholesale.
Um,
yeah,
I think there was 8,000 pounds of opium that we destroyed numbers.
It was a big operation.
There was a,
the uh,
the DEA was involved,
there were FBI agents.
There was a huge,
was a huge crew and it,
and it was good to go.
Uh,
and some of the lessons,
lessons learned from,
there's a that's okay.
So like the first day we're,
I was in one of the,
the blocking positions there and we were taking fire basically from the east end
to the south because the way the different positions,
it was kind of like cross the way it crossed out.
So when we were taking fire from the south,
you had to be aware that like,
hey I can't see him but my bullets can see them in that way.
There's a bunch of guys.
And so we took fire from a tree line that was probably 50 yards from the
compound that we were holding.
And I was up on a,
whereas up on a rooftop with another guy and then I saw like four guys walking
around in cammies and we were getting ready to light him up,
but they were wearing the,
the like the stuff the commandos were wearing like,
hey we got guys moving down here.
We need a head count.
Who's got the Afghany commandos?
Cause these guys look just like him.
And then they came back with,
oh hey,
we got everybody.
No one's outside of our position.
And then so we were getting ready.
I'm like,
don't shoot,
don't shoot.
And then we called again.
They confirmed again.
No one's outside our position.
Then finally,
20 minutes later and they're like,
oh wait,
we had some guys walk out to go to,
I don't know what they do and if they're going to the bathroom or what they were
screwing around doing,
but we could have just completely lit them up.
Um,
we used a lot of 50 cal on that.
We had the air support,
this,
we had everything from Hueys to B one bombers overhead all day long bombs were
falling that the Taliban was absolutely furious that we'd come into this strong.
All there's cops are this much,
you know,
all the opium.
I think there was somewhere like 800 pounds of refined heroin and heroin was
like packaged in these,
these bags that were like this big and it had like a Scorpion on it and it said
like 2008 after,
you know,
it had like a label,
little marketing brand marketing like I,
you know,
made,
made here in Afghanistan or whatever.
And so it was a huge affront to them that we were there.
So after like the first two days we basically killed off every local fighter and
then they started bringing guys up from Pakistan.
And then the,
then it got kind of lively because the local fighters knew every piece of dead
space.
But the guys from Pakistan weren't really familiar with the area,
so they would be bumbling in the open look in the other direction.
You're like,
ah Ha bum,
bum bum,
get them.
Um,
you know,
we,
I think the third morning
this we got up and there's no fighting or like,
well when's it going to,
cause it gets,
it's like you get to set your watch by like,
okay,
Sun's up and uh,
we should start getting some shooting by now and there is nothing and there's
nothing.
And so we radioed up to the,
to the headquarters where like,
Hey,
what,
what is going on?
But they quit and they're just laughing hysterically on the radio.
And they were able to tell this and I can't describe to you how,
but the guy who had the keys to the armory where they were storing all their
weapons and they couldn't find him probably because we bombed him over the night
and they couldn't get into the armory to get their stuff to come us attack us
with that.
You guys going to get a bead?
Yeah.
Oh,
but uh,
it wasn't just an audacious operation that worked out great.
And then do you guys take any casualties during that or did the Afghans or did
the army?
So we had,
um,
a rocket hit the compound over next to mine and our dog handler and one of our
Korman got fragged the corpsman,
the frag knocked a tooth out and then the launch stuck in his tongue.
So he's real lucky at is to slow down the momentum.
And then the dog handler got hit in the back.
Uh,
there were several of the army guys that got straight up shot.
And then here's the awesome part,
like the,
um,
I feel like their call sign was Pedro,
but it was air force medivac.
And as soon as they heard that we were troops in contact,
they lifted it up and they would just be loitering real close to the firefight.
And then like as soon as that,
that Mr port came over and were like,
hey,
we got a guy down,
they came in and it would be like,
I would be watching going,
we're going to get that helicopter shot down.
And they would just come in.
They had a,
um,
many,
the door gunner had a mini gun
and they would just land right?
Like on top of the guy in the middle of a firefight.
We don't care.
And like I would just,
I was so proud,
I could just be crying because it's such an awesome thing to see because it's
complete disregard for their own personal safety and they're just waiting to
jump in there and get guys.
So luckily I'm on that operation and uh,
no one was lost.
And then everybody was,
the guys that were shot were all recover from their wounds.
And what kind of damage,
what kind of damage did you guys do to the enemy?
Significant?
I think it was,
it was pretty significant.
I mean,
um,
there was just a huge amount of drugs and,
and their equipment and things that we destroyed.
And then it just had to hurt them psychologically that they thought that that
was the complete freedom of movement.
And then all of a sudden we came in and stayed there and just did the meet stomp
on them for four days.
And you guys weren't only doing urban situations,
you guys were going into other scenarios where you're like digging in on
hillsides and whatnot too.
Right?
Right.
So later on,
we,
you know,
we that,
that,
that same take the high ground or it will take you because all of our
operations,
I think we only did,
we did two 23 total operations on that thing.
Most of them were multi day.
And um,
so there were only two that we were in and out in the same cycle of darkness.
And,
uh,
typically,
you know,
we would do terrain studies and we're like,
hey,
we got to defend these positions.
And so when we had a compound that we're like,
here's the compound,
this is the compound that we're going to take and hold,
where's the high ground around it?
And then we need to get elements up on that high ground as well.
Uh,
there were also,
there was,
there were two like
time sensitive targets where we came in as a quick reaction force where other
elements where there's another um,
coalition,
soft element and um,
SF element that got an assaulted in a valley and they had a strong point of
building because they'd been hit in this valley.
And then we came in on the high ground,
um,
during the night and then the next morning because that most times the Taliban
didn't fight at night because we had the advantage the next morning when the
Taliban assaulted them,
we were on the high ground behind them and lay the hammer down and then we're
able to,
to get stuff to the word.
Those guys were able to get out that day.
Uh,
yeah.
So we were taking,
we were taking high ground positions quite,
you know,
when it made sense.
There's one operation we were on where there,
what really wasn't any high ground.
And so there were some there,
there were like the furthest we could clear away from the compound that we were
holding was 30 yards.
And then it was a dance like Green Zone and a wall peak.
People could completely creep up.
So we had guys go,
you know,
we identified that were like,
okay,
what are we going to do?
And then someone's like,
hey,
we can put,
well,
let's go put pop flares out there.
You know?
And so it,
that's like going back to the,
to Vietnam stuff,
but guys went out and place those and then boom,
you know,
we,
when,
once the bullets started flying and we were the troops in contact,
the tick,
as we say in the vernacular started to really get up to speed and then all of a
sudden you're like,
oh,
those pot flares are going off.
Okay,
start pumping 40 Mike,
Mike over there or whatever.
And uh,
um,
yeah,
it was,
it was cool.
There's a,
one of the stories we have bat back in Marsha,
the guys brought a,
uh,
the Alg l,
which is like this 40 millimeter chain gun and then it has this,
the new one has like a computer mount that goes on the top.
And so you look at the screen and then you,
you put the little cursor on,
on what,
what your target is.
Okay.
And then it lays is it,
and then gives you an elevation correction based on the ballistics for the 40
millimeter.
And then you raise it up,
you depress the lever
and then just book book,
book,
book book.
So there was a,
there was guys in it in a tree line,
um,
that were shooting at our guys and they had set this thing up and basically it's
a 40 millimeter sniper rifle.
And there they had the uh,
uh,
like a Predator was overhead watching,
giving them feedback on the fire.
So they shoot it,
these guys in this tree line and then they ask the Predator for a battle damage
assessment and the Predator comes back with two e Kia,
which enemy killed in action.
One ran away on fire.
That's good.
And
uh,
what about,
I know you told me a story one time about you guys weren't in the high ground.
He was somebody that there was somebody like across the valley that had a little
elevation on you and you guys were digging in and digging in and digging in.
Sandbag,
sandbag,
sandbag as much as it.
Good.
Yeah.
So there,
there was one,
one in the operations that we were in.
Um,
so while he caught and that this was one of the places that was bad enough where
they actually came at us at night.
So we did our insert hilos dropped us off and we were in our perimeter getting
ready to start our offset patrolling to hit these compounds.
We get when PKM in two RPGs just come zipping overhead.
And Luckily we had,
uh,
whenever we got inserted,
we always had a Paches that escorted us in.
They went over and started hammering these guys,
they mount up getting,
I want to kill him,
kill him like 30 people.
And,
and what had happened was as it turned out,
we were all set from a target,
but where our offset was put us right next to where some other,
a bunch of other Talibans guys happen to be and they thought we were coming to
get them.
So they maneuvered.
Then when we,
we did our offset patrol God to our target guys came at us in the dark.
Uh,
we could see them coming from the high ground.
We laid a fire team,
pushed out,
shot them right when they came around the corner,
completely no factor.
And then,
uh,
you know,
just dirty,
wet.
When they got within,
they came around a corner at 30 yards away from to aaw gunners who just caught
them down.
And then a,
a,
one of those guys,
I think later we figured out was probably some big wig with the Taliban.
So we took that compound and we took the high ground immediately behind it,
but it was in a mountain range.
So there was,
there was always going to be high ground around our high ground the next day,
once they figured out where we were at and then they got on all the high ground
around us and then they just brought it and I can remember.
So the,
where we were out on that high ground,
it was like the crown was too hard to dig.
We always brought 10 empty sandbags per guy so that you could fill them up and
make defensive positions.
We couldn't fill sandbags up cause it was like trying to dig in your parking
lot.
So we just stacked all the rocks we could stack around us.
And then they kicked this thing off with a barrage of RPGs.
And then,
uh,
just a steady stream of PKM fire,
which is,
you know,
their belt fed machine gun.
And I remember being laying flat on my chest and there's like eight inches above
my head are the right.
And,
and by the way,
I'm not,
I took my body armor off cause I was Ooh,
thought I'm gonna take my body armor off and my helmet and I'm like,
Oh God,
my home went back on and I snaked into my body armor.
Everybody did.
And then these,
the bullets are hitting the rocks steadily 80 inches above my head.
And the gunner is,
he's a,
he's 1100 yards away and he's just basically,
you know,
almost lobbing lobbing them in because I had been shooting,
we'd been shooting at the guy a little bit and we just couldn't be kept sliding
behind a rock and it was too windy to get him.
And,
uh,
we had,
I think we had a reaper overhead,
but in the middle of the day in Afghanistan when the rocks are 90 degrees and a
person's 90 degrees,
it's worthless.
They can't see people and the Afghanis are not sitting out in the open world and
kill him.
So I was like,
and at the moment I wasn't scared,
but I'm like,
okay,
I'm getting ready to get shot and I'm good.
I'm getting ready to die by the sword.
This is what I get.
And that would,
and that was it.
And then our Satcom radio antenna got shot and got knocked over.
And so now we had no comms to get air support because we desperately needed to
get some more air in.
And then my boss,
I don't know how he got shot,
he didn't get shot.
But the t you commanders like all right.
And he just got up there and fixed the antenna and uh,
um,
it was hitting it well down in the compound.
Our guys just started lobbing mortars and we used,
uh,
we had the,
they started using the delayed fuses so they were detonating 25 meters above the
ground,
which,
which lays down an impressive frag pattern and tamp things down a bit.
And then we just got hammered and hammered and we're like,
oh this is not going to be good.
I'm
like 15 minutes later they're like,
hey,
we got some air to you.
And it's not,
it's not like we weren't without air cover.
Cause we did have a reaper and I think a Predator showed up too.
But there's limited so to French jets,
soda and the,
a lot of the coalition forces will be difficult with you sometimes when you're
calling for air support and argue with you.
And I'm sure that these guys would have argued with us,
but we just said,
hey,
there were two main ridge lines that we were taking heavy fire from.
And we said,
do you know,
like give us a show of force flights where you've,
they'll fly real low over those ridge lines and see if it pushes their heads
down.
And they came in
right over both ridge lines and that tamped it down cause they got down.
And then a little while later,
uh,
that that slowed things down and it was more manageable.
Now for us,
we'd get our heads up and start to shoot back a little bit.
Then the B one bomber shows up and they've got bombs to waste,
you know,
and they gave us a four,
500 pound bombs on each ridgeline,
air burst at hundred yard increments,
boom,
boom.
You know,
and then that hammered them a bit.
Then we were able to isolate some of the other guys,
use our own organic weapons to hammer the other guys.
And then we were like,
man,
this place is bad the next day.
So we were supposed to extract that ne night and we were like,
hey,
when's our extra?
Oh and at two in the afternoon on the high ground position,
we ran out of water and it was 114 degrees.
So there's no shade,
there's no water.
It's just a massive suck fest.
And uh,
nothing's come until it gets dark.
So we just waited.
The hilos came in after dark,
kicked out pallets of water and Ammo to resupply us and they're like,
by the way,
you're staying for another 24 hours.
Because what we didn't know is that us being there was having a huge effect on
the whole battle space.
And some other elements were able to adjust their position and some of the
Afghan,
uh,
surrogate forces were able to get a whole bunch of stuff done.
But,
oh,
we got that over the radio.
I was like,
oh,
we're going to stay here.
Don't they know that we almost got heavy hammered,
like this is the first time.
Up until then we always had the upper hand.
They weren't really worried about getting,
like,
just getting overrun.
And in this point there was a real fear.
Any second,
now we're going to get overrun.
Um,
and then they're like,
you're staying for another day.
And I remember talking to my two platoon chiefs,
I'm like,
Hey,
we're staying here for another day and you're going to push out and clear this
stuff and we're going to reinforce this position and here's what we're going to
do.
And then they took a deep breath and they're like,
okay,
Roger that.
And um,
we stayed another day and the next day we,
we,
uh,
we got into it.
They threw it,
came at us pretty hard again.
But then we,
uh,
we did a little bit more air support.
We had developed a relationship with the 82nd airborne combat air brigade there,
Apache helicopters,
which are like tanks in the air.
They lived right down the road from us.
And so we would have barbecues with them and we would have,
we would run a range and have them over and then they would come see what the
range and we'd stand around in bullshit.
They broke their sleep cycle.
So this is really important for pilots.
They have got to have a x amount of rest before they can fly and they do not
break their sleep cycle lightly.
They broke their sleep cycle to come support us and then they put themselves at
risk where like Afghanis don't like helicopters.
So when a helicopter shows up,
they'll sink.
They flew low on purpose cause they'll go all of that helicopters low.
I think I can hit it and then they,
they can't resist.
They come out and then they'd have these guys would just hammer on and uh,
they came in the next night and that,
that was awesome.
Yes.
So I was still at trade out while all this was going on.
And I remember I would get emails from you from the,
from your task unit commander as well.
And we were just be talking about,
you know,
hey,
this is what's going on.
And I remember I was signing the um,
emails back to you guys as the spiritual advisor.
I was there in spirit dude.
Yeah.
And we,
and,
and yeah,
we were,
we were hitting back up to you in,
because there was a lot of,
there's a lot of massaging and stuff that has to get done.
You know,
we got like,
I was looking at a picture in the hallway the other day and it's that classic
picture with the yellow smoke and Mikey's there and,
and sets right behind him.
And I never really studied everyone's gear,
but I looked at Seth and sets,
got the enhanced battle rifle,
which is the m 14 that just in,
you know,
the situation it was,
it didn't work for our lasers and our sites.
So they,
these guys up at war calm,
fixed it up so you could use it and have seven,
six,
two on the battlefield.
And you guys all had that and we got there right away and they were just getting
ready to,
to feel the scar heavy
and we got them to field it first overseas,
which is not what they like.
They like to feel that first everyone trains with it.
We got them to feel that oversees.
That was awesome because all of our guys add,
you know,
173 grains of democracy and justice flying out there.
So when you,
when we would take,
when we take an APP,
when we take a compound,
right,
take Kate clear,
clear,
compound,
hold a compound,
the Afghanis would,
they were used to five,
five,
six so they would know like,
okay,
it's pretty windy today and um,
I'm out at 500 yards.
It's not likely you're going to hit me with your 500 year,
five,
six rounds.
So they would be like kind of out in the open and we would just kill him.
And then,
then,
then that,
that circle would go out.
And our guys were regularly getting guys at five,
six,
seven,
800 yards.
Um,
and those are just the scarred heavy with the date.
So here's what they did.
Most of our snipers took the knife force three by five to 15 scope that was on
our,
I'm sorry,
sorry,
sorry.
20 fives,
which that that gun had some issues and,
and would jam a lot and then just put them on their scars.
And that's what they patrolled with.
So they would have it all the way down in three and a half power.
So if you're patrolling you can just swing it up.
It's got a low magnification so you have both eyes open,
you can shoot and then they can put the bipods out and hit stuff far out and,
and,
and those things were,
were in fricking valuable.
And,
and it just brought a whole new dynamic to the battlefield.
and you know,
the scar had some problems.
There's a,
it's not a,
uh,
a direct impingement thing where the gas doesn't go all the way back as a gas
piston,
like the m 14 did.
They told us don't lube those and guys would still lube them and then,
oh,
jam up.
And you're like,
wow,
this gun sucks.
I'm like,
well,
I hope you lose your gas piston.
You haven't put a lot of lube on it.
I don't do that.
Don't do that.
So,
so that worked great.
And that,
that was,
that was awesome that we were able to get,
get that over there.
And the,
the common or at the time basically gave us whatever we wanted and asked for.
This is the support we got from group one was an incredible,
now you guys do,
you guys didn't really take that many can be,
no one got killed,
right?
No one got killed.
How many guys got wounded?
Two guys got wounded with frag.
Um,
you know,
we had a couple of concussion injuries where guys got knocked out.
Uh,
and it's hard to quantify how serious that is.
And then,
um,
on,
on our turnover operation when seal team one came to relieve us is when,
uh,
when,
when Dan can,
Austin got hit by the IED and lost both his legs and,
uh,
that,
I mean
Ho horrible event and,
and thank goodness we're just like,
there's so many things that lined up to save Dan's life because we'd been
inserted for an offset patrol,
went in there,
um,
got,
got in there,
uh,
secured the,
the bizarre,
and then we push guys up to high ground like we always do except for the Taliban
suspected,
you know,
oh,
well they'll,
if they come to take it,
they mined the entire high ground.
So as that element was pushing up,
um,
there was an explosion and then there was quiet and then two,
you commander gets on the radio.
Hey,
was that a debt?
And uh,
on,
oh,
I see who deployed with you came back.
And he's like,
it was not a controlled that we've got some wounded.
And we're like,
okay,
work through it.
Get on the Satcom,
the,
uh,
the 40 sevens that had dropped us off.
It was an sop for them to have a flight surgeon on one of their birds.
And so they hadn't made it all the way to back base or it may have been that
they loitered around for a little bit.
That could have been too.
So they were right there and there was surgical stuff right there when cause
Dan's wounds were absolutely horrible.
Um,
and then once the EOD guy started,
once that happened,
and it was lucky because the charge went low water or snow it going high order,
it would've killed like six guys.
He discovers that they're in a minefield,
basically his metal detectors getting overrun.
So he's got a bay,
a net or a big screwdriver and he's probing the way out in front of the guys so
they could get Dan out and onto the mat of act that later.
Got them back.
Okay.
How long had you been on the ground for like a matter of 10 15 minutes?
No.
Um,
w we did like we did an offset.
So we,
we patrolled in for like three or four clicks.
So,
okay.
It was a little your hours.
It wasn't a couple hours but it was inside of an hour.
That's why I'm not sure how long was 40 sevens were loitering or if they were on
their way back and they were able to turn them around,
but they,
they were back quick and they had that surgeon on there,
which I think really made the difference for,
for Dan who,
you know,
now he's the guy's running marathons.
I haven't run a marathon.
Lat Yeah,
I feel like such a loser.
He's competed in the Olympics a couple times right now.
He got a gold and the Paralympics,
right?
There you go.
Yeah.
He's awesome.
Awesome guy.
Yeah,
that was,
that was devastating.
Devastating.
I remember
we got word back that,
you know,
one,
one of the guys and we just assumed it was one a year guys actually cause I
don't think we even knew the turnover that,
you know,
the turnover was taking place.
I assumed it was one of your guys.
But,
you know,
and then,
then I heard it was Dan and um,
I remember the first phone call that I got and I was like,
is he gonna live?
Oh yeah.
And at this point they were like,
yes,
he is.
Because I mean,
I know it was like touch and go,
but then the first person that I don't,
I don't remember who it was,
was like,
yes,
he's stable,
he's going to live.
And I was like,
then we're good to go.
And I just remember thinking,
thank God he's,
you know,
he's gonna make it,
you know.
Yeah.
The uh,
the like are on like the second or third op we were there,
one of our guys were mic,
we're doing an op with the one we always had Afghany commander knows with us
because they were the partner of course though the Odh we were doing.
And one of them stepped on a mine and it blew both his legs off and part of his
arm.
And,
uh,
one of our guys got cut in the face with his femur.
And then there were some issues where when they were putting,
all of our tourniquets were failing because it had a plastic windlass that was
was going.
And so the,
the one guy,
he that got hit and then he got caught in the face with his femur and it messed
him up mentally for a little bit.
And I didn't know what to say to him.
So I didn't say anything to them.
And I've,
you know what I wish I had,
because I've come to a conclusion now with a lot of this pain that everybody
carries around that,
that it's,
it's a poison you carry inside of you and if you talk about it,
it lets it out and then,
then it's kind of detoxing you a little bit.
And so like,
I don't know,
you know,
if you're listening to this and you're in a situation,
if someone's gone on something through horrible and you don't know what to say,
say something,
just sit down there and just talk with them about it.
You know,
ask how they're doing,
see if they can get it off their chest because it helps.
Yeah.
I the same thing.
We had guys that got,
like I had one guy that got shot in the chest plate and got shot through the
camelback on his back.
Those are two different operations too.
I mean like,
so what does that do to you when you're thinking,
how close was I to just getting killed twice,
you know,
in two different scenarios and for sure I think,
if you don't,
what does,
you know,
what,
what do we do in the teams?
Like make a joke about everything.
Everything's a big joke,
which probably helps in some cases.
Uh,
but yeah,
let,
let you definitely got to,
if you get the opportunity to talk to people about what's going on and what I
think it does is even more than like,
well I'm sure,
I don't know,
cause I'm not a psychologist,
but okay.
There's the idea that you're like letting this stuff out,
right?
I'm going to let this stuff out.
There's also the idea that when you talk about something you,
you articulate what you're thinking and you have to like put it into words that
somehow they become a thing that you can manage you.
Yes,
it makes complete sense.
Like when you don't talk about it,
it's just like you have a conversation with somebody about whatever you,
you want to debate with somebody about some subject.
If you never debated about it before,
you're going to be at a disadvantage because you don't really understand all the
INS and out,
but when you actually talk to someone about it,
then you say,
Oh,
here's,
here's a point that I could make here and here's our point that could make
there.
If you don't talk about this stuff,
it's just sitting in there and it doesn't get any better.
You don't understand it any better.
You talk when you just like we were talking on the last podcast,
how when you teach something,
you understand it more because you have to detach from it to look at it from the
outside.
Well,
if I explain something to you,
I'm explaining it to myself too.
You know,
And I told you this yesterday,
you know,
when,
um,
when I had Tom Phifer on the podcast who was in world war two,
Korea and Vietnam and got a purple heart and all those in,
and I asked him,
I asked him some question about losing guys when he was a battalion commander in
Vietnam 60 years ago.
I didn't say that part about like,
you know,
what was,
how did you guys handle casualties or something like that.
And I don't know what the question was,
but here he is,
this,
you know,
army colonel retired army colonel and he's talking about the guys that he lost
60 years ago and he got choked up.
And I remember looking at him and I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
this is the way I'm always going to feel about the guys that I lost.
It's never going to go away.
And like just hearing him talk about it and seeing that reaction,
I was like,
okay.
And that's what I tell all my,
all my bros now I'm like,
Hey,
you're always gonna feel that way.
Like it's,
it's just,
here's a guy that was in World War II,
Korea and Vietnam.
He got a purple heart in all of those and he gets choked up talking about the
guys that he lost in Vietnam and Korean War,
World War II,
but you know,
I specifically asked him about Vietnam.
So when you talk about these things,
I think you get some kind of handle on them because you have to articulate them
in such a way that you can then,
it's like a,
what?
You have to name your enemy,
right?
You have to,
you have to name your enemy.
They say,
if you don't name the enemy,
then you,
how are you going to fight them?
Well,
it's the same thing when you actually say,
Hey,
you know,
I really feel bad about this,
or whatever,
or I think I could've done this better,
or I think I made a mistake,
or I wish we would,
or whatever it is that you're thinking,
you know,
whatever,
survivor's guilt,
whatever that thing is that you have.
When you say it,
you're,
you get to look at it and you get to look at it from the outside and go,
okay,
yeah,
I'm explaining this to Jason and I'm telling him what I'm thinking.
And then while I'm explaining it to you,
I'm explaining it to myself is what's happening.
And that's why I think talking about it,
not only is it get it out,
but it gets you a handle on it somewhat.
Yeah.
The process of it coming out of your mouth and then back into your ears are
maybe letting different parts of your brain adjust and deal with it.
But
yeah.
Check what else?
Uh,
so you come home
from Afghanistan,
Amy,
so like [inaudible] and here's another thing I want to talk about too and,
and you brought this up in this,
the book you are covering the last couple podcasts about fear of like once that
first bullet goes by or that it just like everything shuts down and you just go
to what you're supposed to do and then you do it.
It's like in the moment all emotion goes away.
There is no fear.
But then afterwards and before is when you have the fear.
Like I was lay in my bed there and I would completely was,
would picture notification going on for my wife.
Like I could see the guys in blues driving out to my house or you know,
okay,
this is a good chance that I'm going to get severely maimed and I,
I could picture myself sitting in a wheelchair outside of,
uh,
you know,
the,
the paddock that I have my horses in and I can't even ride them anymore.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you know,
now I'm getting emotional about that,
which is kind of,
it's odd to me,
but that,
that's,
that's weird how,
how it,
you know,
when you're in the moment,
you're not afraid later on when you're thinking about it is,
is when these,
you start to freak out about it a little bit.
There's no doubt.
And this has been confirmed over and over and over again,
that the waiting is the worst.
I,
that's just,
it just,
you're just anticipating and then once you're going,
why you're going and you got stuff to do.
And I was never in situations where I like didn't have anything to do.
And there was other things happening where I was like,
well,
the I,
the few times I've been mortared where I'm like sitting there waiting for a
mortar to either hit me or not hit me.
That sucked a lot,
but it wasn't a,
it wasn't like,
it wasn't like an hour though.
You know?
It's like foam foam.
Okay.
We got about 30 seconds.
I Dunno,
maybe a minute before we find out where,
where it's going to be at.
But I also think that,
you know,
if you're scared of dying,
it's going to be real nightmare all the time,
I think.
Okay.
Yeah.
And like paralyzing.
I said that one point in us while he caught where I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to get,
this is what I get.
It was just,
was,
there was not fear.
It was just an acceptance.
I'm going to get shot here pretty soon.
I wonder how bad it's going to hurt or burn or whatever it is.
And it's like,
all right,
that's going to happen.
Okay.
Now,
later on,
you think about it.
Um,
there's one other thing.
I think on an earlier podcast,
people were asking a question about if you had a routine,
because I had a really definite routine that I went through prior to going out
in,
in Afghanistan and it wasn't like anything religious,
but I w I'd sit down,
I'd be in my room and he,
you know,
we'd have everything but like,
well we had everything in our room,
but we had a ready room and all that.
So Iris had sent me the CD from this country,
singer,
core blonde.
I'd put that down.
And then the first thing I'd go through as I change out every battery in all of
my gear because you got like your belt or headsets,
you're not,
all that stuff's getting new batteries.
Then I would go through and look at all my battle maps,
clean out the ones from the last one,
get my new battle maps for this one,
study them.
Then I'd always,
always,
always carry 24 hours worth of water with me and then pack out my food.
Then I would go get fresh batteries from my radios.
Then I would go through all my gear,
strip it down,
put it back together for anything that I had,
any special gear and equipment I needed for that up.
There is a,
uh,
later on I like to carry a 60 power spotting scope because I was spending a lot
of time on high ground nature that was all clean up.
Um,
make sure that my radio is charged with Crypto,
all that stuff.
It would take me like two hours to go through that whole process and then we
would go outside,
we would do our comms checks together and uh,
um,
go out and get on the helicopters and get after.
And so that,
that routine right there is like so good because if you had all that stuff ready
and you just sat there for two hours,
that would not be fun.
No,
no.
And I mean,
you gotta go,
you gotta check everything three or four times.
I remember riding with a guy on a,
on a ride and his,
uh,
his a battery died on his nods in the middle of the,
you know,
when he's driving on a convoy,
I'm like,
good grief.
He didn't put a fresh one in the costs,
like 90 cents.
Dude.
My first deployment to Iraq,
we were doing that and we stopped.
We stopped changing batteries for every op like after a week because the ops
were like an hour long and all of a sudden we realized we were going to run out
of batteries.
Like we just didn't have enough batteries.
So we just went to like,
hey,
carry an extra battery and if,
you know,
if it dies then whatever,
change it now we're always all night.
Yeah,
you guys are going on all night isolated.
You know,
we were 10 feet from our Humvees or whatever,
20 yards from our home.
These have a big stack of batteries and it didn't matter.
It's totally different scenario.
Yeah.
I think that,
um,
I would always be super busy with doing stupid,
you know,
officer stuff ever for old out,
getting this brief,
checking in with this guy,
whatever,
doing all that stuff and I,
I would just get all ready and I,
it seems like I would work up until I got into home.
V
T you commander did too.
And it was hard
because he would go on the op already on arrest deficits.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then when you're going to stay out there for two days,
eventually,
you know he's got to go down.
But they,
we figured out like,
uh,
um,
he would,
he would pass it off to one of the other OIC.
He used
to be the GFC cause he didn't want me to be the guy talking to the Jay Tac about
what to drop.
He had more sense.
Well I would be pretty liberal.
Here's a picture of me and Dave Burke.
Good.
Yeah.
Good deal days.
And it's,
it's in downtown Ramadi.
I think it's on the roof of Cop Falcon and we're both just completely asleep
sitting there and just asleep cause and the same thing,
cause when I'd go out a lot of times I'd been awake and you know late,
all of us would be awake for a long time.
So you get in the field and you're like,
cool,
I can sleep now.
And again that was like,
okay.
So that was like one of the hardest things as a leader is like you get there,
you get in the oop and everybody wants to stay awake and that meets,
we're all going to hit the wall in like six hours.
So it's you gotta like go and say,
hey you four guys get in there and I need you to take sleep.
So you're ready to bump out on the security positions.
Are they fighting positions or whatever it is because it's common.
Yeah.
Everyone's just going to hit the wall at the same time and you're all asleep.
So,
all right,
so that's a real,
was that the last op you did was with Dan,
was that the very last opera?
Did you do a couple more?
I don't remember.
It was pretty close to the last dot because one of our platoons had already
redeployed at that point.
Um,
you know,
in,
in leadership you're the first one there and the last one to go.
So we didn't go until the last bird,
but I think,
I think that was our,
if it wasn't,
it wasn't one our last one,
it was our second to last one.
It was going.
Was coming home from this deployment any different than coming home from your
other deployments?
Oh yeah.
I've been there for eight months and it was the most kinetic deployment of,
of my career.
So yeah,
they,
and,
and uh,
NSW started doing that.
The third location decompression stop where they're like,
hey,
before you get home,
we want you to sit down and blow off some steam and a sit down with a,
you know,
psych and talk to the cycle a little bit.
And our,
our redeployment flight kept getting bumped.
So we redeployed like I think eight days later and then we were supposed to,
and every day it was like,
Hey,
the bird's gonna go tomorrow,
get up muster.
And they're like,
nope,
maybe tomorrow.
And we did that for eight days in a row of filing.
We got on it and it was getting so long.
I was really angry at me.
Now you just let us go home.
And uh,
they held their ground and I'm really glad that they,
you know,
held their ground because when we got to the other location and you start
drinking,
I was just a frigging idiot.
Drank way too much.
Um,
but I needed it.
I needed to blow off some steam and stuff and it was good to have the other guys
to talk to and,
and,
and to be somewhere where,
you know,
uh,
my loved ones didn't have to see me being just a complete buffoon.
And then,
you know,
and then I got home.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
that,
that it took a lot.
So,
so I live kind of in at the time was living in east county,
San Diego and the area I live in is really similar to areas of Afghanistan.
So I would find myself in my yard,
you know,
and I was back and constantly scanning the high ground and,
and doing a technique called ballooning and that's where,
you know,
I'm here and then all sidestep here and then all backstep here.
And it's so like you're just making it difficult if a sniper's aiming at you
that you're hoping that he's squeezing the trigger as you're stepping to the
side and you're going to step out of his,
his crosshairs doing stuff like that.
And then,
um,
you know,
when,
when you go eight months and every stressor that you have is a fight or flight
full Broan stress or whether it's the enemy shooting your indirect fire coming
in,
it's hard for your body to come back and then differentiate between somebody not
agreeing with you on something you just said or anything else.
Um,
my sleep was completely jacked up based on us operating a lot at night.
Uh,
and I,
I had,
I've always had issues with my sleep.
So on the deployment I'd started taking,
take an Ambien,
then they were given to giving it to me.
And so,
uh,
I was having difficulty sleeping without that.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I think it was the first night or second night I was home,
the dog started barking and I kept a gun on the nightstand,
which is just,
just an sop.
Now it's in a safe,
cause I have kids but dogs are barking.
I roll out of bed,
grabbed the gun and I'm at the ready waiting,
just like,
oh,
okay.
And then Iris,
you know,
rolls out of bed and she or looks up and sees me standing there naked,
holding a gun next to the bed,
breathing heavy,
scanning both the entrances and she's just like,
oh wow.
What came back.
And you know,
I didn't get a chance to talk about,
um,
my wife and where I met her,
but she was a wrangler on a ranch that,
uh,
we go to a lot for training when I met her and she's just,
just hard.
A good,
good,
good partner,
soulmate and uh,
and she's been extremely patient and put up with a lot of stuff that most women
wouldn't have.
And when I came back,
I was doing,
I was drinking heavily just in mainly,
you know,
as I assess my drinking issues,
it was because I was so wound up that it would be four beers is to where I could
get myself back to where everybody else walks around in their daily life where
they're just calm because I was just like her.
Um,
and that's just a from one is not sleeping and then the other one is just coming
back from a deployment like that you get,
it takes you a while to decelerate when people are shooting at you and all these
horrible things are happening.
And then now you're back in society,
but you're,
you're not really where you're back here in the u s but you're not really,
you're,
you're not all the way back.
And so,
and,
and my temper was like a millisecond fuse.
We'll get mad about stupid stuff and all kinds of stuff.
And finally she said to me,
she said,
you know,
hey baby,
you're not,
you're not the same guy you were when you left.
And,
uh,
I really want you to talk to somebody.
And so immediately I got on the phone,
I called up the psych and I started seeing the psych and talking through a lot
of this stuff that I had going on and started working at getting better.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's a long process and it was,
it was helpful to talk to those guys.
Uh,
it to say that you have PTSD and,
and is,
is somehow maybe admitting a weakness.
And I dunno if it's,
you know,
how do you define PTSD?
For me it's like,
okay,
well if I'm in a crowd,
I'm getting hyper alert.
And when I came back from deployment,
I was hyper alert all the time.
And adrenaline is just a constant,
steady drip of adrenaline going in.
And that's why I was kind of a drinking heavily to calm down.
Um,
you know,
and in the vicious cycle I got into it,
the Ambien and that's a,
and then my sleep and jacked up.
And then inflammation and all the other health health issues that came with
that.
So that was like kind of the first step.
The second step was at this time I came over to the training of detachment and,
and you know,
2010 and was now running the land warfare section for you.
Um,
and doc parsley,
Kirk Parsley was our,
are a diving medical officer,
group one and he's a seal.
Later on went and got his,
uh,
his,
you know,
doctorate and became a doctor.
He kind of at that point was discovering that all these health issues that we
were dealing with was,
we're were revolved heavily around sleep.
And so he was able to help me like get off the Ambien,
start doing stuff to take,
you know,
natural things to get my sleep back in order.
Did you ever do the sleep study?
Did he puts you on the third?
He didn't,
but I,
I did a sleep study later and uh,
um,
I have sleep apnea and so I've got a c pap machine and asleep with,
for that and that helps.
But you know,
sleep and diet are a linchpin.
Click sleep,
diet and exercise.
There's three pillars of good health probably.
Is there a fourth pillar?
Probably like hypnosis or I don't know.
Those are the big three I would say.
And uh,
getting that sleep fixed up help my mental state a huge bit and how my physical
state,
I was in terrible shape at the time.
I had a lot of different joint pains and ailments and so that was good.
You know,
I was taking Melatonin and he goes,
how much Melatonin you take?
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm taking six milligrams.
He's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
You know,
you need,
your body is going to not make its own.
And ideally you get to the point where you're not even taking,
you know,
like some magnesium at night to to help you calm down.
And so that,
that started me on the,
on the path in that I was really glad because otherwise I know guys that can't
sleep without ambien and I don't think that they're really,
they're not really getting into the sleep and it's just,
it's not good.
And that this time you were working at trader came back and took over the land
warfare,
a senior enlisted role there as it should be.
Yeah,
that's a,
that was my dream.
Usually guys don't ask to go to an island and I was like,
Hey,
please send me out there.
This is what I like.
And uh,
that was good to go.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's really interesting and we talked about this earlier as we applied pressure
to the different troops,
we would see troops that were,
that were loaded with superstars.
They had so much raw talent,
but then they didn't own their mistakes and they were just terrible.
There'd be terrible.
I really like what,
I know you guys are good to go.
What is going on here?
And then we would see troops that necessarily did not,
I'll have a whole lot of raw talent,
but they were very humble and they were,
they kept their,
there are plans,
super simple and they would just,
they would be the troops that,
that like we couldn't the op for just couldn't,
our opposition forces couldn't keep up with them.
That's just a fact and it's over and over and over and over again and again and
again and the people that people that,
it's interesting too because you might think,
well,
if you're not humble,
then you're going to be cocky and if you're cocky with the training guys,
then they're going to be more judgmental and they're going to push you harder
and they're going to jump on everything that mistake you make.
It's not like that.
It's like it's so clear that when a,
when a troop was humble,
they would fix themselves and fix the problems and the mistakes that they made
and when they weren't.
You know,
you get four or five guys,
six,
seven guys in a troop that are cocky and arrogant and they not only are they not
owning their own mistakes,
but they were blaming everyone else inside their own troop.
It just turns,
it's so horrible to watch.
It's,
it's horrible to watch because they're at each other's throats.
They're blaming each other for everything and no one's taking ownership.
It's just a total nightmare and it has nothing to do.
It's like even completely objectively looking at a troop,
you just,
you just watch him fall apart because someone doesn't say,
Hey,
you know what?
Maybe we should just work together and try and do better,
which is essentially all you need to do is say,
wait a second.
It took us 12 minutes.
The trade that guys timed us on getting our headcount,
leaving that building,
it took us 12 minutes and in that 12 minutes we took four more casualties.
Maybe we should look at how we're getting our headcounts,
whatever,
just whatever little thing,
and if you're an arrogant person,
you just,
it just,
I think it.
Guess what?
Then you end up with a bunch of new guys that are all arrogant because they're
all just imitating you.
You know?
They're all imitating the senior guys.
There's not a new guy that checks into a team goes,
you know what?
My chief seems a little bit arrogant.
I'm going to be more humble.
That doesn't help.
No,
you're a new guy.
You're like,
I'm going to act like my platoon chief.
That's what I'm going to do.
And that's what you do.
And you end up with a whole task unit of just people that don't want to say that
they did anything wrong.
Mean again.
It was just horrible to see,
cause it'd be guys that were all over me and guys,
we like,
we know everyone,
you know,
no everyone on,
on the west coast and know every guy like they're all friends and be like,
Bro.
No.
And it was so hard.
That was the hardest part of the job was,
was was having to,
you know,
you're looking at your friend and saying,
Bro,
man,
um,
I'm not like,
you're not,
I'm not just saying this,
you guys are doing really,
really bad and you need to fix some of this stuff or it's,
you're not going to get through it.
You're gonna get reloaded.
And yeah,
that was,
that was the worst part of the job there.
My opinion.
Absolutely.
And then it's super tricky just to,
to be able to debrief these guys and doing a manner where you're,
you don't sound condescending.
Yeah.
I mean,
God,
I loved that job.
I would,
you know,
go out there.
I had my little voice recorder and I would sit there and I would take all my
notes and the voice recorder,
she can't write while you're,
all this stuff's going on.
And sometimes I would just record the guys as they're freaking out,
total panic,
screaming at everyone.
I just record them and I'd get back and I'd be like,
hey man.
Okay.
When you guys got strong pointed in that building,
what were you thinking you wanted?
If want to do?
He's like,
they just needed to move.
And I go,
okay,
let me do it.
Let me just play what you were saying.
And you'd press play on the recorder.
And the guy would be like,
and you couldn't even understand him,
couldn't even understand him.
And they'd be like,
man,
Bro,
this isn't just like,
this isn't just me.
And there's some guys that did it didn't like me,
you know,
or whatever.
It's like,
it's not just me.
I like you actually.
I think you seem like a good dude.
I'm just saying like,
these mistakes are bad and they're not just made up,
man.
They're just like,
I'm not just making it up.
You guys ran to the wrong target and the whole task unit brand to the wrong
target.
You're in charge of the assault and you ran to the wrong target and everyone
followed you.
And that just,
you know,
you didn't,
you didn't do what you were supposed to do.
And that's not good.
And I'm not just saying this because I want to be cool.
I'm saying this because it's not good.
It's just,
it was crazy.
And w the great opportunity of that is it was a nonstop experiment to where you
could watch how guys organize themselves and how they,
their organization structure responded depressure and you could see like,
oh well these guys are using decentralized command and we can put all the Dang
pressure we have to bear short of killing every other guy and they can still
function.
Or these guys have over centralizer command or there just isn't any.
And I can put a fraction of pressure and then it just cracks everywhere and
falls out.
And that's cool that that,
I mean,
again,
I learned so much from the several years that I was doing that,
but I could see the personality traits that guys were exhibiting as they came
through there.
And then what,
how they were organized functionally and what worked and what
yeah,
and the other,
and I just set a bunch of negative stuff about how much it sucked,
but it was so awesome.
You'd get these studs,
these young seal beasts,
he fives that would just be like off,
take her this element,
we're moving.
And you be like,
I love this guy.
And just,
they would just be awesome.
And so you'd see that all the time too,
of course.
And so that was what made it so cool.
And yes,
it's the ultimate leadership laboratory to,
to experience from the outside,
from the instructor cadre perspective of we're going to put 28 platoons through
this little problem,
the same problem.
And the only differences,
and you could say there's some difference in the guys,
but there's really not,
there's actually like the seals in the platoon,
they're good,
they're solid defined.
There's a couple of knuckleheads,
there's a couple of great guys,
there's a couple of guys,
there's guys in the middle.
But that's not the difference.
The difference is so blatantly clear,
the leadership that you just get to see that over and over and over again.
So that's awesome.
Yup.
How long did you stay there for?
It was there three years.
And then what came next?
You made master chief [inaudible] and then wrapped up your time at trade at.
And then when it was time to
go over to team five check,
I went over to team five.
And the way the progression as you,
you do a slot as the operations master chief and then the next we're built on a
two year cycle you'd fleet up to become the command master chief.
And uh,
operations is just,
it is a crazy job because you are responsible for every single moving part that
the seal team does.
So you're looking at what all nine platoons are doing for training.
You're involved with where everybody is going to deploy.
Uh,
all the gear.
They got all the ammo that the order,
anything in between outside you're dealing with all the other commands.
Um,
and then so halfway through our workup,
the ice isol went and took Mozal and uh,
then deployed,
they split up how the team was organized so that that kind of threw a wrench.
It,
uh,
how we were deploying.
We had to come up with a plan to possibly deploy half of the team during unit
level training.
Um,
and it was busy,
but then it was,
was a fantastic experience because basically learn how to do everything.
And then every time,
so working with,
with like if someone came to me and they complained to me about our admin
department,
and then I would go to admin and like,
Hey,
what's going on here?
And then I would find out that like,
well,
half the blame and sometimes all of it lies with the guy complaining about it.
Or Hey,
this other unit over here,
they're not doing this right.
And then I just go over and talk to them and find out that hey,
they've got some issues.
I don't know about that.
We could help them out with or we're not doing everything correctly.
And so I got,
I took that stuff that I learned from,
you know,
like Danny,
Carolyn,
Steve Hines and monetary size and started to apply it outside of just a platoon
level but to a command level and relationship level.
And uh,
it,
it worked out great.
We got,
we got a lot of stuff done.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I'm rambling a little bit but there you have that,
that,
that stuff.
Every time there,
there was,
every time there was a complaint,
this isn't doing the right,
they suck at this.
I dig into it and there are a couple of times I didn't dig into it and then I'd
wind up with egg on my face and now I just dig into everything.
I take what someone tells me,
like somebody gets in trouble over the weekend and it's like,
okay,
this is what we heard right now.
The first story is never the real story.
And then let's just,
hey,
we don't have to make a call now.
Let's wait and let things develop and find out what the real facts are before we
do something.
Knee jerk that we can't take back.
And sometimes it winds up that it's worse and sometimes the winds out it's then
better.
Uh,
I remember one of the things I heard a general say on,
on,
on the deployment that I was on later on,
he says,
he says he's,
he's not going to make a decision until he has to,
like,
they were like,
hey,
we want to do this.
And he goes,
do I need to make that decision today?
No.
Okay,
then I'm not Gunna,
cause he can let more facts come in.
He can deal with more stuff.
Uh,
which made sense that it was general Nagata,
which was the soccent commander when that stuff went on.
And he was,
uh,
I've never met him personally,
but he believed in real flat communications.
So when he sent out an email,
there'd be like a couple of hundred people cc'd on it.
And he,
cause there's a tendency for people on staffs to use the flag officer there.
They're working for,
they're using them like the,
uh,
um,
the wizard of Oz,
right?
They're like,
oh,
the general just said this.
And then you're like,
well,
I saw his email and that's not what he said.
In fact,
here's,
let me forward you the email and highlight it.
And everyone else would be cc'd and no one does that.
But there's,
I,
I've seen it happen a lot of times with other leadership who doesn't,
don't use flat comms where people below them,
we'll start saying,
this guy says this,
or this guy says that,
and start doing a little bit of manipulation to maneuver whatever their agenda
is or just get things going the way they want to do.
But one thing I heard,
you know,
that's on that,
uh,
don't make a decision until you have to.
And there's a weird dichotomy in that because you know,
every,
there's,
there's plenty of quotes that are,
are the opposite of that,
which is,
um,
you know,
a good,
well,
like we said,
the though good plan right now is better than a great plan executed tomorrow or
whatever,
or you know,
you gotta be decisive.
And the reality is there's,
and,
and I've,
I've,
I say this a lot,
which is,
if I know that we're a,
we get intel,
if there's bad guys in this building,
in this town somewhere,
and they're like,
we want you to go hit it.
That doesn't mean it's like,
okay,
I decide right now,
yes,
we're going to go hit it.
We load up the vehicles and we start driving and we drive there and hit it.
No,
we actually go,
okay,
well let's let the inflammation develop and we'll start planning.
So I made a decision.
The decision was to start planning.
The decision is to go hit the target and then it's like,
okay,
well now it's nighttime.
We have a good plan,
but we're not sure.
We haven't confirmed the Intel.
Okay,
well let's,
let's drive to a forward operating base and get staged,
right?
So we've still flexed.
I've decided to do that,
but we haven't decided to go hit the thing,
but we're still prepared to,
if we need to.
We've moved in the right direction and then we get,
you know,
Intel that,
well,
we don't know,
but a vehicle arrived at this person's house and we think it might be him.
Okay,
well let's push to a staging,
right?
We still haven't decided to hit it,
but we've moved in that direction.
But this happens with businesses too,
where there's something unfolding,
a new market,
right?
Hey,
just new market might open up.
Okay,
let's invest all of our money into this new market right now.
No,
that's not a good move.
What you do is,
okay,
let's,
let's find out.
Let's,
let's invest a little bit of money and find out how big that market really is.
Okay,
cool.
We do a little study.
Oh,
it turns out that that market does look pretty big.
Okay.
Let's do a little research and see what it would take for us to push into that
market.
Okay,
cool.
And so you're moving in the right direction,
but you're not just jumping in with this decisiveness to say,
okay,
I've seen all I need to see.
I've decided that we're just going to go all in right now.
That doesn't make a lot of sense.
Sometimes there's other times where it's like,
guess what?
We're standing in a hallway or we're standing in the street and we're getting
shot at,
we're going to get into a building.
That's what we're going to do.
Like there's no,
we're not going to think about,
we're not gonna move towards the building.
No,
we're going in the building cause right now out here,
we're going to die.
So yes,
be decisive in those situations.
Be Decisive when you have to be decisive.
But if you don't have to make a decision,
the big decision right now,
and you can make a series of smaller decisions,
iterative decisions that move you towards what you think decision you will have
to make,
then go that route.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Okay.
So you guys deploy to,
and this is when you guys,
uh,
get an emotional,
no,
not as a following deployment.
Okay.
What'd you guys do on this deployment?
I went to the,
the,
the command split up.
So the um,
CEO and,
uh,
the command master chief,
we're up in Iraq and then,
uh,
I was at another spot nondisclosed location on a crisis response element with
the expo.
And that was,
that was six months.
That was sick.
Wow.
We did five months cause at the time they said you have to be front door,
the front door in six months and because you can't predict the airflow,
we did a five and a half month
deployment.
And then that was a big eyeopener to,
because we on that deployment,
I start,
I was going to an embassy once a week.
Uh,
how the boys handle it.
I mean they,
they did good.
We had a,
um,
we had guys kind of spread out in different spots.
And uh,
there was a big operation that went on on there that one of the national mission
force did.
And uh,
our guys participated in it and it was,
it was a good like shooting deal.
Uh,
nothing happened up in Iraq.
I think it was frustrating for them.
Um,
and then by the nature of how everything was,
there was a really strong,
slow strike process.
So when our guys could see like a vehicle born,
I e d driving towards Iraqi counterparts to blow them up,
it would take 20 minutes to get clearance to drop a bomb on and,
and,
and only 15 minutes to drive there in like five minutes to drive there.
So you,
they just watch it happen live on TV and they're like,
ah.
So that,
that aspect of it was frustrating and there wasn't,
wasn't a real clear decision made on what was going to happen at that point.
So there wasn't,
I don't know,
the guys up there didn't do much,
but just spin,
spin and spin and spin,
which is really difficult.
Okay.
Get ready.
Oh,
nevermind.
Hey,
get ready on ever mind.
And uh,
um,
yeah,
that,
that was,
uh,
that was good.
So it was a good deployment.
Overall,
it was a good experience for me to kind of like,
because I was the senior enlisted guy where I was at and so that was great.
And,
uh,
um,
came back from that and we did our change of command and then I fleeted up to be
the command master chief and you don't really know who you're going to get
paired up with when you're in that leadership role because there's a commanding
officer in a commanding mass,
Steve.
And as it happened,
I got paired up with a guy that was just awesome and I'd known for ever,
and the two of us are a lot of like personality wise,
which we really,
you know,
like we,
we went to a couple of leadership seminars and they're like,
you guys are almost the same person,
so hey,
here's what you're going to have to watch out for it because both of you are
really blunt and um,
yeah,
I really won the lottery.
It was a,
it was a real pleasure working for him.
Um,
he was a fantastic leader in what he did really well specifically was,
he communicated a lot.
So He's,
he always speaking with his,
his Xo is opposite officer and myself.
And then the task unit commanders,
he spoke with the all once a week,
he would have a meeting with them once a week,
you know,
and he was all,
all the way down to the platoon OIC end.
He did it in a manner where he wasn't stepping on other people's toes and there
was never any,
there was never any,
any guessing on where he was coming from or what he expected.
And everybody knew that he cared about them was,
was,
is his first priority.
And then the mission came after that.
So that was really good.
But Hey,
you know what,
if you,
if you messed up,
he don't hold you accountable.
He,
he,
oh,
he give,
give you a written counseling.
And he did that for some of his guys who just did some shady stuff and they're
good dudes.
And he was like,
okay,
well,
hey,
you know,
hopefully this stops here and did,
do,
does a written constantly.
So,
so that was good.
But uh,
yeah,
again,
it's the same message that we talked about in the last podcast,
which is just knowing where you stand.
Absolutely.
Having predictability and know when,
when you know a guy's got a reputation,
like,
oh,
if you step out of line,
you're going to get formal written counseling.
That tightens people up immediately.
Whereas if you think on this guy's kind of a pushover,
guess what you do?
You cause more trouble and you cause more problems.
Yeah,
you really do.
And it,
and it was like,
it was all as an escalation with it,
but it was a,
it was straightforward.
And then everybody,
all his understood like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm not mad at you.
These are just the standards we have here.
And you did this.
Here's the consequences is that,
you know,
we need you to fix yourself.
I'm rooting for you to fix yourself.
I'm not mad at you.
And then let's just move forward from here.
Uh,
got back from that deployment and then I got back in February.
You started this podcast and December Iris had started listening to it and then,
like I said,
podcast six is when I started listening to it.
And then I was caught up within a week because I was able to do it with my,
my longer commute.
And then just you talk about,
I wish I had this Ivan,
I had the luxury of having this when I was in a really important leadership
position,
threefold as a husband,
as a father and as a seal,
right?
And those and the priorities are almost always the same or it's weighted heavily
husband,
father seal.
And so all this stuff that,
that,
that is discussed here through all these lessons from these books and all that
it can take and apply to every stinking aspect of my life.
And I did it.
And like the hardest thing for me was that to really get introspective and
honest with myself about what my shortfalls where,
and it's not something that you can do overnight.
It's not like I can get a shot and get inoculated at something that is water
tortured in.
And then I just growing so much from it and like I'm gone.
It's,
you know,
the,
the like starting with the Dang see of machetes seasoned in the Michelle.
That was like the first really dark pocket and I was driving and I was wincing,
listened to that.
And I'm like,
why did he do that to me?
Um,
but then I appreciated how good I had it right then then,
then.
And so now as those,
those podcasts are so dang necessary to understand how evil I could,
cause I could,
I could completely go down any of those roads.
And then once you understand that that's in your heart,
you can control it,
but then you can appreciate how good you have it.
And,
and,
and you've got that like the,
the um,
the episode that you did on the my Lai massacre,
I had to pull my car over because I was crying cause I was so ashamed that this,
this is,
or like I was just like,
can't this story be about somebody else and not Americans.
And then
later on when,
when I,
when guys make chief and I talked to you about this,
I'm like,
Hey,
when my guys make chief,
we,
we have to put them through all this training.
A lot of the training I don't think is good.
One of the things I did for them is like,
hey,
we're going to listen to these three podcasts in my lay was one of them.
The other one was a steal my soldiers hearts,
which was an awesome podcast and awesome lessons and they're all awesome
lessons.
But it was all good because the guys listened to it and we'd have discussions
and then,
you know,
you came in and,
and uh,
we VTC and talk to him and that was such good stuff.
But going down that road and then being in all these different situations at the
executive levels,
levels of leaderships in the seal teams,
and I could see in real time,
I'm like,
oh,
okay,
this is uh,
this is I,
yeah,
my face is getting flushed and I'm a little emotionally attached to this idea of
my Mike.
My fists are clenched.
What did he say?
He told me to breathe
and then I come back and like,
oh,
or someone said something and I disagree with them and I just ran headlong into,
you know,
a pill box and like that did not work out well.
Maybe I can learn to finesse it.
And then it worked out great because our,
I think we did the feedback I've gotten anyway is that we did really good at the
team and we dealt well with a lot of other people.
Uh,
and,
and so that is,
is a huge degree for myself was having the podcast to learn these things and
miss military history and then being able just to be introspective and improve
on,
uh,
on my life is all.
And then having these discussions with my,
because she listens to the podcast all the time and when we discuss it and it's
just been good for,
for us across the board.
Um,
you know,
when we deployed on that deployment,
and that's during the deployment,
when we did the,
uh,
the Clarence into Mosell,
we had one platoon that went to an area and they were working on under the
conventional Marie every,
well,
it was all,
we were all working for the conventional,
the conventional forces in Iraq in 2016,
17.
They were the main effort we were in support of and then our guys weren't to a
location where they inherited a pretty toxic relationship and they took some of
the lessons that you talked about and they went in there humble.
They said,
hey,
how can we help?
What can we do?
Oh Hey,
when are your,
when do you have,
when are your normal battle rhythm meetings?
We want to send a representative there so we make sure we're doing everything
right and we're getting the word and all that.
And they really leaned into it.
They turn that relationship around in a matter of a month completely around and,
and then they were in an area of Iraq out west that was not,
there wasn't a lot going on out there at the time,
but that colonel was so impressed with them and liked them.
He bent over backwards to make sure that he could get them outside the wire so
that they could get after it.
And we were able to get them outside the wire and at the end of deployment,
all five of our platoons had been in combat.
They were the last ones,
the fifth platoon that hadn't.
And then they got the opportunity to really mix it up on to operations.
And it was 100% because of that,
that colonel liked them as people and trusted him and wanted to see them do
well.
He wanted to celebrate it.
And when people don't like it,
they want to see,
they'll walk across the street to see you get screwed over relationships are
stronger than the chain of command.
Absolutely.
And they had written in there,
I love this cause I've copied this on their,
on their whiteboard in there.
They're,
they're joint opera there,
jock,
they had at the top in all caps relationships equal mission success.
So when one of their [inaudible] went over and talked to a Marine Corps e five,
they were really cool with them.
They didn't manage their own security.
Like the Marines did security around their camp.
They would bring dinner out to the guys that were standing watch at night just
like it was.
It was awesome.
And then everybody,
there was a,
you know,
a real,
a real sense of teamwork and stuff out there.
Um,
so that was good.
That was,
but you guys did some real tough fighting inside of Mozel.
Yeah.
Now our,
our platoons that were up north,
um,
you know,
when they kicked off the liberation of Mosul,
which was the biggest military operation since the invasion of Iraq,
and there were,
I believe,
three different main lines of approach going towards the city.
And Isis pretty much controlled everything on the outside guys.
The first couple days of that,
there were semi trucks that were loaded with explosives vehicle born.
IED is,
that was a semi,
like,
I don't think outside of the Moab,
we don't have a bond that's carrying that much stuff coming at them.
Um,
and that's where,
uh,
you know,
EOD chief finding was killed.
Um,
on the first couple of days when a,
our guys,
uh,
had gotten into an area,
they were,
they were partnered up with the,
the Peshmerga,
which are the,
uh,
who were the guys that Kurt Kurt's,
yeah.
Hurts.
Yeah.
So they're partnered up with them and they were pressing into an area and they
got into an area that was just too laden with ids.
And they were having to back up their,
uh,
their Matt ve,
the truck they were driving in and Jason had the door open so he could make sure
that he was in the same tire tracks of that he'd just driven over.
Unfortunately,
they driven over a crush plate,
wants it,
crushed it halfway.
They hit the rest of the cross plate.
And,
uh,
it was a daisy chains of explosives.
It went off,
he ate a bunch of it,
hit him right in the face.
It was a fairly horrible experience for our guys that were there because he was
still breathing
okay.
Biologically he was alive for like the hour that they were with him before they
could finally get them mad of back to him.
That was too hot.
The Medivac wouldn't come in,
so they had to offload them off the truck,
get them in the back of a pickup truck and then drive through all this heavy
fire and a lot more ideas to get them on,
on,
uh,
on board,
the medivac and then,
you know,
then he expired.
And uh,
it,
it's the worst case scenario period.
And it's something that we drilled.
We started drilling,
we call it a Keiko drill for when you lose a guy back on the strand.
And we would do full blown drills like,
okay,
here's what we need to do,
um,
okay
to to cover down on that so that we're ready and an on a little bit
superstitious.
I think if we practiced to do something a whole bunch of times,
it's not going to happen.
And then it happened.
But luckily it's something that we,
it's not lucky that it happened,
but it's something that we drilled and more so we had like a book because
there's an incredible amount of emotion and everybody wants,
everyone gets excited,
they all want to do stuff in there.
Sometimes you can do,
there's too much that you can do and you can confuse the situation.
So we just opened up,
we had the Keiko book,
we opened it up and we're like,
our admin or guy is like,
hey,
what's step one?
And it goes down.
He goes,
alright,
we need to do this.
What?
Step two,
we need to do this.
There's no way we would remembered that we went through it,
went through the steps.
One of the things that,
that I was pretty adamant about is because I had a good idea,
although I haven't experienced it directly about what my guys had gone through
that were there with him.
Um,
and I wanted to get a,
a psych out to just help them unpack some of the stuff they went through before
the end of deployment.
So he could do two things.
He could get out there and help them unpack what they were,
you know,
what they went through.
And then he built up some rapport.
So at the end of deployment on the,
the next stop they had some rapport with them.
So the,
the group sent,
sent the guy out.
Now this is like three weeks after this happened because the best thing to do is
to do something.
And the guy stayed busy because there was a freaking war to fight.
But then when stuff taper down for them and now like others downtime,
Hey,
guess what?
The psychs coming out and he's going to hang out there and you don't need to
speak with him,
but he's available.
And typically he,
he,
you know,
he'll get out there,
he puts the thing up.
Hey,
he wants to be quit.
No one signs it.
But then he's just there and at lunchtime a guy hits him up and then later on
another guy hits him up and
yeah,
and the guys went through and there was,
there was heavy fighting up until the day that,
that we redeploy.
Like team seven basically came in and were doing turnover ops and going out and
doing stuff there.
And Mozal we had just,
there was a little bit low of a law one.
Eastern Mozal was finally cleared and then there was a big reassessment on
moving over to the other side of the,
uh,
the river.
But,
uh,
um,
it,
it was,
it was busy and it was,
uh,
it was pretty good.
I mean,
we had a couple of vehicle borne IED that got within a hundred yards of our guys
before they were able to kill him with,
and then the,
the,
the drivers got like a kill switch on him.
So when he dies,
it gets released,
it gets released in detonates and there was no shortage of the,
I think there was at least like seven or eight of these things coming at us a
day.
And then they,
they'd been prepping for months.
So they were laid in all across Mozal.
There was a garage underground that had a v bid in it.
And so as the frontline move closer,
all of a sudden this car would just drive out and drive right into the Iraqis
and blow them up and there is no time to,
uh,
hit it with a hell fire or,
or,
or stop it or whatever.
And they may have them come in pretty quick.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
going back to the casualty plan,
it's,
you're giving me a hard time,
but you were harassing me saying like,
when are you going to write your protocol book?
Because I've talked about,
you know,
how you've got to have protocol for certain situations
that aren't right?
Like you said,
things that are real emotional,
things that are moving real quick.
Things that you know you're,
you need to be thinking about,
but you won't be able to think clearly about when they're actually going on.
And that's what you're talking about.
You know,
you guys put together a protocol to follow and the navy has one and the teams
have one.
But you know,
you got to look at it and actually understand what it means.
You can't just open up a book that you've never looked at before,
so,
but,
but that protocol idea for,
for your life is definitely a powerful thing.
Weather,
especially for things that are going to be emotional and,
and rough to go through if you have a good protocol,
commence the protocol.
Step one.
And you also talked about the guys continuing to be busy and that's absolutely
true.
If you're going to sit around and wait,
if you're going to sit around,
you're just going to think about the,
the horrible event you just went through.
And that's not gonna go well cause you're not ready to deal with it.
So get back to work,
work,
let it settle a little bit and then you'll,
you know,
you'll,
you have to deal with it later,
but you do have to deal with it at some point.
Yeah.
I know that like one of the Times that I got to go out to the,
to the,
uh,
to basically the flott with our guys who are going advise and assist and they
would be about three blocks back or four blocks back from the front lines.
Um,
the civilians that lived in Mozel would just move away from where the fighting
was and then just kind of mingle around just outside of it and then go back to
their houses.
So we were at this,
this one location where the guys were providing support to the Iraqi cts and we
had snipers up on rooftops.
We're able to see all the way to the front lines and take shots.
And then we were also using mortars pretty heavily.
We got some 80 ones in that are just frigging awesome.
So
two things art.
So one thing and another story I'd have to,
so there's all these civilians around which a little nerve wracking because
who's who,
right.
And there are a bunch of kids,
there were some kids right next to it living in the building next to a,
with their families next to where our trucks were parked.
And uh,
they were really nice kids and they spook pretty clear English and they wanted
candy and stuff.
So we were chatting with them a little bit and,
and messing around.
And then,
so we were there all day and then in the evening a bunch more kids came out.
There was a whole group of kids and I don't know if they just come in the area
or was the evening and they just want to come out and play.
And so there is,
we are in this area where there weren't a lot of buildings,
so we're right in the middle of this big field.
So,
you know,
we could see anything coming and the kids were all playing.
And then a salvo of one twenties came in and so 120 millimeter more boom,
boom.
And they basically kind of bracketed us.
But then where,
where one of them landed was right where those stinking those poor kids were.
And I looked over there and I saw like this beautiful little girl hop in a way
in the smoke and she's missing a leg.
Okay.
I saw a guy run out and snatch up a little body
and he's just wailing.
I thought,
you know,
I thought about my kids at home
and what those people are going through and how awful it must be.
Yeah.
And how are we just got to redouble our efforts to stop this freaky crap that
was going on with sold because it is just so unsat because little kids are
little kids are little kids,
you know,
wherever they're from or what,
you know.
And to see innocent shattered like that.
It was rough.
But that's,
that's part about,
you know,
knowing the darkness and what does that do that makes me appreciate my kids more
and then never pass up an opportunity to hug him or tell him I love him or
anything like that.
Yeah.
And that does those kinds of stories right there.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
I
all right
pretty regularly have to explain to people that there are evil human beings in
the world,
that they're,
those,
those people that dropped those mortars,
they don't care about those kids at all.
And I heard other stories from guys coming back from Mosul after you were,
there were one of the biggest risks that was going on.
Was the,
the guys doing the EOD job?
Well,
what does the EOD guy do?
He dismantles bombs.
Well they do that in the lowest possible risk way that they can,
which often means if we find,
or if they find an IED of some kind,
what are they?
Do?
They just blow it up in place.
They send a robot robot over there and detonate the thing and just blow it up.
And that makes your job a lot less risky.
Well what was happening over there,
it was suicide.
There was suicide bombers.
Okay.
So what do you do with a suicide bomber?
Well,
what you do with a suicide bomber that comes up that's wearing a suicide vest,
you shoot them and kill them and that makes your job pretty easy.
Cause then you can then,
once you've got a dead person with a bomb on their chest,
you can send a robot over there and blow up the bomb.
Well,
what happened and what the,
some of the stories I got told was that isis was putting these suicide vests on
little kids.
And so you can't shoot the little kid and you don't want the little kid to get
that name.
And it was one of the riskiest things that they had to do.
And you know,
that's,
and again,
that's what,
that's the kind of thing that,
that,
you know,
there's,
there's uh,
like,
okay,
there's a lot of,
I'm not saying America is a perfect place because it is not,
but
that kind of duty,
you hear a story like that.
Yeah.
And you know that there is a,
some random EOD guy with a wife and kids at home and whatever else he's got
going on.
And he puts all that on the line to try and help some little Iraqi kid from
getting blown up.
That's say what you want about America.
But that right there is America.
We went out to the,
to the,
well I,
I the guys were going out to the floor every day.
I got an opportunity to go out with him another time when they were right on the
edge of,
of Mozal going into it.
And the building that they were occupying,
um,
was a school.
And one thing I noticed as I was walking through the buildings of the school is
that on the walls of the school,
like okay,
inside the classrooms had all the Disney princesses,
Dora the explorer,
all this stuff that our kids enjoy there.
So it's two fold.
There's,
there's,
there's a thought like all our western culture and lifestyle is going to get
overrun negative because western culture on the whole,
while you said it's not perfect,
is still the best thing going.
And it is completely contagious.
And even over there in Iraq and an art school that was controlled by Isol,
they're little kids are looking at the Disney princesses and Dora the explorer
and you know,
that stuff,
western things because it's good.
It's appealing.
Yeah.
And that that gave me,
that gave me a tremendous amount of hope
in just our culture and way of life
forward.
That's the whole idea of months ago when I had said that,
oh,
you want to solve the problem in North Korea?
Give those people I phones so they can start watching youtube because you watch
a couple of youtube videos and you look around at your,
you know,
baron neighborhood where you're eating like a water with salt in it is your
dinner and you watch a youtube video of people eating steaks and Mcdonald's and
subway and you think yourself,
the something's not right here and it's not going to take real long before those
people say,
look,
we're doing this wrong.
And you've probably heard that story about Gorbachev would,
Gorbachev came to America and went in if you're the story,
no.
Gorbachev came to America from the Soviet Union and he went into like a a a Vons
or whatever supermarket he went into and he went into the cereal aisle and saw
that there was 390 different kinds of cereal in there and he realized that they
needed to stop what they were doing.
Cause you know how many different types of cereal there was in the Soviet Union.
One,
you know that's it and when you try and control everything it doesn't work.
And actually I remember you called me up one day,
you're like,
hey this was like I was listening this podcast,
this applies to everything cause like it's the same with government.
I'm like,
yes it is.
You can't control everything.
If one person tries to make all the decisions it doesn't work.
I was actually going to read this Thomas Soul chunk from when I,
when I,
last time I had Jordan Peterson on because he lays out this thing about how the
government,
the government trying to control the pricing of some kind of pelt,
some kind of pelts in,
in,
if the government raises the prices,
every hunter goes and goes and gets all these pelts and it turns them into the
government and then the government,
what do they have now?
An excess of pelts.
And so now where are they?
Do with them all?
They don't do anything because there's nothing to do with them because they
don't have,
they aren't needed.
And his whole cycle unfolds where things just don't work with centralized
command and the things like Dora the explorer and the Disney princesses and
Thomas the tank engine and all of these Mikey and the dragons,
these things are going to spread.
And those evil bastards,
what do they do to try and stop it?
You know,
what do they do?
They try and control anything,
any and any form of freedom and especially freedom of speech,
you know,
controlling the Internet.
All those things and it's disturbing to see.
But I believe that like in Jurassic Park,
echo movie reference my [inaudible],
what's he really?
Yeah,
he's like one of the first guys to appear on the screen.
He just walks past.
He's in.
I still still in that movie.
I think the line,
his life will find a way,
right?
Life will find a way.
That's what happens.
You know,
with all these,
um,
these,
these folks will remember those folks in Mozel,
they'll remember that.
They'll remember who gave freedom.
And by the way it was Iraqi troops,
which was amazing to hear the Iraqi troops fighting hard and sacrificing.
Because in Ramadi it was pretty rough to get the Iraqi troops to take lead.
And when they would take lead,
the insurgents would be waiting for them and would be deal heavy blows to those
guys.
And it was a nightmare to watch.
But it's,
it's awesome that they stepped up and they did the house to house clearance.
What do they have at least supported by coalition forces,
by Americans firepower and all that.
Yeah,
but guess what?
How many,
how,
how many people did they lose?
Uh,
at one point we thought we were going to lose our entire partner force.
When they first kicked it off,
they were losing,
they are losing 15 to 20 guys a day and,
and we did the math.
We are like at this rate and it was because our,
our strike process was really Sloan and hadn't gotten decentralized yet.
That was fixed later.
But we're,
we're like okay,
at this rate in three weeks these guys were in our entire part of horse is going
to be gone.
Yeah.
And what's really impressive is there,
we lost a battalion aid,
Ramadi,
they deserted and w they had shown up,
they did a couple of operations,
they took some casualties and they left.
And so for,
for those guys,
when you were in Mosul,
take massive casualties and stick it out,
that shows you that how much that's just leaves and it's,
it's,
it's in comparable
day one was third before it was their CTO,
their counter terrorism unit,
which is,
they're like premiere basically tier one.
They were all really,
really good to go dialed in.
And it was just,
the fighting was so brutal.
They were losing guys heavily.
Yeah.
And the other funny thing,
somebody put this on social media the other day and it was like Jocko Willink,
he predicts the future or something like that because I was with on with Joe
Rogan and Joe Rogan's,
I get,
what do you do about these isis guys now?
How could you ever defeat them?
And I was like,
if you gave the isis problem too,
like a Marine Corps second lieutenant and said like,
Hey,
figuring a plan and how to beat these guys,
they could do it.
It's like there's a bunch of bad guys.
You're surround them and move through and killed them all.
That's what we're going to do.
And he's like,
yeah,
that actually did happen.
And,
and that is what happened.
And it was,
it was beautiful.
And the amount of attrition that took place was
awesome.
Yeah.
And for those people that think that you can't kill an idea,
they're wrong,
you know?
And then there was some of the stuff where isol had gotten so hysterical was
something,
there was a video.
They,
there's one of those,
you know,
like do those horrible videos.
Yeah.
And it was,
something happened over in Syria and they released a video where they,
you know,
they killed like nine guys,
but they were from the local area.
And then I guess the tribe was like,
Hey,
can we have the bodies back of our guys you just killed?
And they're like,
no.
So the next day a suicide bomber walks into the isol headquarters in that area
from that tribe,
which the way the tribal is more,
they're willing to do that and boom,
clocked off,
killed like 30 people.
They just,
you know,
and I think there's one or two people that are kind of hardwired maybe to do
that out of a thousand and they have to do these videos and force people to do
that stuff because it's not in their nature.
Certainly as an in mind,
another,
that's another big misconception is like,
oh,
they're just willing to die.
No,
they're getting coerced and forced into those situations.
You know,
that's,
that's what's actually happening.
Like you said.
Sure.
Is there one out of a thousand that's like so brainwashed that they're like,
yes,
I'm going to go be a Marger.
Sure there is some of those,
but most of them are,
hey,
if you don't do this,
we're going to kill your whole family.
So which one do you want?
And the guys go,
yeah,
okay,
go ahead.
Go on over there.
And I'm talking about situations to where they've got,
they all like a guy strap to a post with the thing on and then they tell someone
go stab him.
And the guy did,
no one wants to do that.
You don't like there.
They were doing what the Japanese were doing in world war two.
Oh,
okay.
I see what you're saying.
Hey,
go hike off some heads for training today.
Go kill some poor Chinese farmer.
Go and no one wants to do.
Most people don't want to do that.
And that's like an in their situation to a lot of those people that are going,
I don't want anything to do with this now go,
you got to do it.
Or the result is we're going to kill your family.
And then they just get into a situation where they're doing it and it's not
good.
Anyhow,
on a positive note,
like on that deployment,
I cleaned my dang diet up as a result.
As you know,
Peter Attia being on this podcast and nine,
I'm listened to Peter t as podcasts and keeping smart on my health and started
doing a,
basically I did pretty strict Kido.
There's a couple of weeks where I ate nothing but eggs and sardines and man,
that is boring.
Oh.
But uh,
I felt,
I've found,
you know,
my inflammation went away.
I dropped pounds and I was getting in good shape.
And then I started experimenting with intermittent fasting,
which is something that I'm still doing now and now is,
that's good stuff.
You start that,
uh,
during deployment before Flint on the deployment limit,
I'm like,
Hey,
okay,
I'm going to quit eating sugar.
Cause you,
you'd mentioned sugar's bad for you.
And I never really paid attention to it because we're sugar is bad.
And then I'm like,
uh,
okay.
I see.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to stop eating sugar.
And I was eating big salads and stuff like that.
And uh,
and,
and there was a guy that I was deployed with is really smart on this stuff and,
and he's like,
well,
hey,
if you're,
if you stopped eating sugar,
then you need to quit eating that yogurt and that milk's got a lot of sugar and
it guess what?
That fruit has got a lot of sugar in it.
So man,
then I started looking at labels,
getting smart,
picked up a book,
read it on basically,
you know,
how I eat now is,
is,
is round about a Paleo thing.
Like I try to avoid grains and carbohydrates and stuff that's processed.
Um,
because the other day you're like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm staying,
I stay that way.
But then you're like,
but if I go to someone's house and they say like,
Hey,
do you want to,
you know,
do you want a piece of bread or whatever?
Yeah.
I eat it.
Cause there's it,
there's another aspect to that I don't want to be the Vegan guy is like,
hey,
you know what?
I'm better than you because I'm a Vegan,
so I'm,
I'm the,
I'm better than you.
It.
Yeah.
And so it's like really uncool if someone offers you food to say no.
So that's,
that's where,
that's something that I weigh out.
If it was like,
oh,
okay,
I go over to your house and we're having pieces of dinner,
that's what I'm going to eat because I can afford to eat a piece of pizza or
that guy.
And then you just gotta watch out for this slippery slope because it is,
I say no to bread all the time.
Oh No,
no,
I'm good.
Um,
and then like you said,
if it's someone,
hey,
if it's,
if it's a situation that unfolds where it's like,
oh,
I'm going to look like I'm going to be bringing attention to myself is really
what it boils down to.
I'm going to make everyone talk to me about me and my little thing it's like no
I'm not that important.
You know,
I'm just some dude who like is weird so I'm not going to make a big thing out of
that and breads handy.
I mean eat some meat without getting your fingers all dirty.
Yeah,
no it's,
it is,
it is handy and the the lettuce wraps while good in theory and actually have you
had someone make a burger.
I had one the other day was an iceberg.
I said I asked for like lettuce on a burger and it was iceberg lettuce cut and
like basically in half.
So it was big too big giant chunks and it worked really well.
I was pretty,
cause normally it's like,
oh,
they give you that one big piece of lettuce that's all wilted.
By the time it gets you,
you can't pick that thing up.
It's not happening.
You actually got to use a fork and knife to eat a burger,
which in its own right is kind of disturbing.
If we're eating burgers and we're using a fork and knife,
we don't respect that.
I mean that's just not something that we're doing,
but all of a sudden we are,
if we've got wilted lettuce on the his
shit.
And so you started,
so you cleaned up your diet.
What did you weigh when you went on deployment?
193 pounds and I'm five foot six.
And then what'd you weigh when you got home?
Uh,
I think I was one 65.
How did you feel?
Mentally?
Way Better Way and,
and Akbar's lead already cleaned up your habits.
So you were basically getting on step right as,
as I've been,
I've been on step probably for two years and,
and you know,
it's a sleep psych.
Anything else?
It just got to be disciplined with it.
Um,
I don't get up at four 30 in the morning.
I get up around five 30 or six,
but I'm really careful that that like,
you know,
the lights are all out because for me even stupid little lights will wake me up
and,
and it's quiet and all that.
And then I got,
I got one of those weighted blankets,
which is pretty cool.
Do you must've told my wife about that or iris did because we both have a
weighted blanket now too.
It's not on my side of the bed.
It's just on her side of the bed.
Yeah,
they're not cool in the summertime cause they're too hot.
Oh yeah man.
I just go to sleep and sleep.
I don't wake up at all.
Told him til the next morning and I'm like normally you wake up a couple of
times during the night and that they needed to get under there and you feel all
safe and you're like,
oh I feel like I'm in the womb.
You're,
you've got the weighted blanket,
you got the c pap machine,
you're just keeping it real.
One of our mutual friends that has a c pap machine.
And his wife was like,
you know,
yeah,
when you,
when you mask comes off d do you know I'm trying to wake you up so you can put
it back on.
And he's like,
don't,
you know,
don't just leave me alone.
And she's like,
well what if your mass comes off and then you stop breathing?
And he's like,
just let me die.
So that's good.
So you come home from that deployment
and then what you do when you got back,
did you over to trade and three became the command master chief there and then
started,
you know,
preparing her roommate,
making sure all the fundamentals that you stayed in place.
We're still there and they were still there.
The guys are just really hard and doing a good job.
And then,
uh,
and how was it overrunning unit level training and,
and seeing that and then,
uh,
working myself out of a job,
getting the,
the,
the guy that's my replacement set up to take my job in and,
and here's the deal.
Like as I leave naval special warfare.
Okay.
They are so good to go.
And I see the younger guys now that are coming up at every level.
The people like to complain about the millennials and I,
I really don't see any issue with them cause they're doing good and it,
and when I measure myself against who they are when I was their age,
they're way better.
I'm like,
oh my goodness.
Biggest problem I have with millennials right now as I look at him and I'm like,
how are you so much bigger and stronger and smarter than I ever was when I was
22 I told you this the other day I roll in here and I hear some like guys
training over on like another.
Matt and I looked over there
and you're clearly young frog men and there's six of them and they're all
dripping with sweat because they've been getting after it hard and they all look
like they're yoked and just ready to go start just killing people.
And I'm like,
what's up fellas?
Yeah.
Like we're getting ready to go to land warfare.
I said Legit,
just so happy.
Then it just,
yeah,
you're,
you're right.
These guys in,
in the teams right now and in the military at large.
If you're going in the military,
you're doing it for a reason.
You know when you and I joined there one no war going on,
we were hoping there would be,
but you're going to now look me,
you know what's up,
you know what you're doing,
you know what you're stepping into and now retirement you're going to go,
I think so I'm really excited but 30 years is a long enough time to where I'm
like,
Ooh,
yeah.
My hardest part is that like I'm glad that you're going with a feeling like,
hey,
things are good to go is the hardest part is you start thinking that you like
that you are so critical and now like,
oh what?
It's like no,
there's 10 guys that are just as good as me,
better than me and they're all going to get in there.
They're going to do a better job than I could've ever done.
And,
and then the other thing is like when you hear some rumor or whatever about
something going sideways and you get,
you get all freaked out because do you want to be like back where you can help
and you got guys going on deployment.
Like if something,
it just like that you have to you,
it's just hard to let go.
And I mean I'm not saying you're going to be able to let it go,
but it's,
it's hard to not just think about it the same all the time.
Like
it's hard to,
it's hard to come to grips with the fact that you're not in the teams anymore.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
And then that's what I mean,
I'm super appreciative that I'm getting to work with echelon front because of
work that the best thing about being in the teams is the peer group.
And so I'm trading right into the same peer group of just a bunch of awesome
people and then getting to go.
And I've really enjoyed like a third of my career as a seal team five.
The other third of it was at trade yet.
And I've really,
really enjoy working with people.
Um,
teaching,
passing stuff on learning.
I'm always learning and that's,
um,
I'm super excited about it.
Yeah.
It's like I said,
once you get over the fact and um,
I'll give you a little heads up.
Have you cleaned out your locker yet?
It's,
it's like 80% done.
Okay.
Yeah,
that last 20% sucks.
That's the worst part for me.
Loading that stuff into my van and knowing and then your,
your car,
your access card doesn't work anymore.
It's just like game over and you just drive out.
And you know,
especially for guys like you and me and you know,
you even 10,
I mean I was in for 20 years.
You were in for 30,
but
I mean,
how many memories do you have at the seal team?
One grinder at the seal team,
three grinder at the trade,
at building.
It's like my whole life is right there.
And you,
you know,
when you're leaving you're just [inaudible].
It's scary because all of those memories are there,
but man,
they're good memories.
And I know that if I pick up the phone guys will answer.
And uh,
yeah.
You know,
when not when faculty died
last year and I was like the what I felt like
all that.
Yeah.
I just felt like all of that memory,
all that memory that he had of us is gone like that he had of me and all my
little running mates that I used to run around with.
We were all team one guys.
We are all in like,
he had these images of Austin knew us when we were little kids and kept us out
of trouble and all that stuff.
And I'm thinking all of those things you eat,
which he had a perspective that only he could have.
I was like,
oh,
those are all gone.
And that was,
that was a crappy feeling of just,
damn,
why does that have to go?
And I never got him on the podcast either,
which is a freaking shame.
Yeah.
Um,
but the good thing is,
like you said,
we're still all just kicking it.
Yeah.
I mean really it's like just this
naval special warfare in the organization or team.
We're just in that for that little time and then it's shaped us way more than we
shaped it.
We had our influence and it'll just keep on going and that's what that's like.
There's a piece of piece of onsets never,
ever,
ever going to die as long as this country's around or are there are guys doing
frogman stuff?
There'll be a little piece that it gave us and we gave it.
They're moving forward.
Yup.
That's good to go.
It's about as good as it gets about as good as it gets.
I think that's probably a good spot.
And
the,
we might both be retired Echo Charles,
but we're not done yet.
In fact,
we're just getting warmed up.
Plenty of fighting.
I'll be it in a different way.
Sure.
That is left to do and we're going to do it.
Okay.
You got any suggestions on how we can stay in the fight?
Seeing the fight and on the path big time.
Yeah.
Okay.
First thing you get to grate a little bit more direct
relationship to the expression.
Fight Jujitsu.
You're not doing it.
Do it for many benefits.
So we always talk about not going to go too deep into it.
I wanted to,
cause I was thinking about it.
Okay.
You know,
some people don't call a Jujitsu match or did you get to training or what?
Some people do,
some people don't.
So this is what I kind of discovered or realized that if other types of fighters
or or martial arts practitioners,
they tend to not call Jujitsu will fight.
You know like,
oh no,
it's not a fight,
it's a match or it's whatever.
And then you have the totalitarian kind of attitude,
which is like,
hey,
anything that you're struggling against another person or another force,
it's a fight.
Even for you going to the grocery store looking for a certain kind of,
it can be a spaghetti sauce
sometimes,
especially when I'm doing it for somebody else.
It's another element in the last two,
the way I look at it.
If you and I roll yes and we go hard.
Yes.
Is that a fight?
That's a fight for that car?
Well,
you can't cause I look at it in that way.
Anything that I'm struggling against another person or force or in your case at
another person and force,
it's a fight.
So the,
you know,
with you,
that's essentially a good example.
Unless fighting all out war,
total war,
a war.
It's good to exercise that fee and lives,
that whole book psychology for the fighting man.
It's just so good.
But just starting off with total war and when you start to view your life
through the aspect of just total war.
Yeah.
Oh,
because they were,
now we're taking it to the next level.
This,
this workout.
I'm going to be total war.
Yeah.
This person that's trying to get somebody,
somebody hit me up on social media today,
said said he was getting emotionally blackmailed.
Okay.
He said,
what would you do?
And I was like,
I'm not getting emotionally black,
black male,
no factor stifle your emotion to say,
well you're not because well it's like you don't even have emotions,
so how can you blackmail you on prison?
So yeah,
I mean,
but makes sense.
So I don't know though,
because what emotions sometimes can be more,
you know,
more of a thing for certain people,
a peanut kind of everything.
Yeah,
for sure.
Unless if you have no emotion,
so then you're gonna have real problems.
It's like me,
but you should learn to control your emotions.
And one thing that can help you learn to control your emotions is Jujitsu.
Jujitsu,
because it's an exercise in prepping for all out war in life.
Very good direct anyway.
It won't doing Jujitsu,
we need a gate and rash guards.
That's essentially the uniform uniforms for the shoe shit soup.
And you get that at the best ones anyway,
at origin or didn't mean.com.
That's where you get it.
It is in Farmington,
Maine,
all made in America,
which is not a small deal.
Not a small deal at all.
You can say,
oh,
whatever.
No,
it's,
it's a big deal.
And what's awesome about speaking of America is going up to Farmington,
Maine and seen a factory with 40 people working in it.
Craftsman making stuff here.
Yeah.
Bringing back a town.
Right.
Bring it back in an industry.
That's what we're doing here.
Movement check starts other clothes,
joggers,
athletic gear,
apparently genes from what I hear.
Yeah.
You don't know about those yet.
American denim and then we've got supplements.
Yeah.
Jason Gardner talks to me about origin Jocko supplements coming at you live.
Yeah,
I am on the,
uh,
joint warfare in the morning,
two at night.
Krill oil every morning.
And uh,
I am on the milk train.
I am on the mold train.
You know,
when I get,
when I want to have some dessert and I'm like,
Eh,
you know what,
all almond milk.
And then a scoop of the uh,
mint chip hit that with a stick blender.
It satiates me.
And then every morning my coffee,
I got a scoop of the Vanilla Malt.
Actually,
now that you know that,
you know the video you made with Tim Tim for where he's like probiotics.
Yeah,
it was Jason.
Jason was like,
you know,
I wasn't sure if I was going to get that stuff,
but then I saw it had probiotics
just ordered it
cause that's what you needed.
Did you know that was you?
Yeah,
I pretty much figured it out.
I'm like,
Hey,
that guy is in his mustache when he gobbles.
Exactly.
I was on the site looking at mine.
I'm like,
man.
So first of all,
it said Kido complaint on there.
I'm like,
Oh,
good to go.
Because a lot of the protein stuff is loaded with sugars are,
and then I saw probiotics and I'm like,
okay,
I'm done.
Here's the,
here's the,
here's the issue.
It's either loaded with sugar or it tastes horrible.
Cause even you put whatever a sweetener,
artificial sweeteners tastes horrible except for one,
the one that we use,
which is not artificial.
It's actually from nature itself.
Monk Fruit.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you can get all those from origin main.com and,
and I,
I also realize that you haven't tried the warrior kids strawberry milk yet,
and I'm going to get that to you.
You're going to get nuts,
bro.
It is ridiculous.
So get some of that check.
It's true.
Also,
Jacqueline is a store,
as we all know by now,
it's called Jocko store.
So you go to [inaudible] dot com this is where you can get your shirts more rash
guards,
trucker hats,
flex fit hats.
We're doing both.
Did we?
Do we know which one sells more?
They're even really,
are you just making that day where even when I checked,
when did you check?
This is like such as damn what he's doing.
He just said that he did.
Eddie says
kids brought a bit of riled matter.
You can't look at me and say it's equal.
That's so just don't lie to me,
Dude.
It doesn't work.
I'm like,
smell it.
How would this all,
I'll check it out.
We'll get back to you.
[inaudible] we're good now.
We're good now.
There's no factor.
I'm good.
Now here's the thing.
They're not trying to look at me and tell me something that you don't know.
At the end of the day,
it doesn't even matter because look what if I'm like,
hey,
I like flex fit.
Oh,
but the trucker hat.
Semetic we're not talking about it.
I worry about being truthful.
I want the hear what you want.
Tell me the truth.
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
I'll report back and calm about that.
Is that cool?
Anyway,
hoodies,
like I said,
women's stuff on there.
If you want to represent,
we are on the path.
That's where you can get the stuff to represent.
You also get some,
uh,
Jocko white tea.
You can get it from commercial wherever.
Yeah,
it's cause it tastes good and it's awesome for you and it gives you an 8,000
pound dead lift,
which is not,
you know,
light.
Uh,
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't yet.
Otherwise Echo is going to keep telling you,
just subscribe.
He's going to invade your dreams until you subscribed or whoever you people are
that haven't subscribed yet.
You're crazy.
Well,
this is 168 podcasts.
This is hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of hours of listening.
But you didn't click subscribe.
We've got issues with you.
Just subscribe.
Don't forget about the warrior kid podcasts.
Trying to tee up a couple more right now to get them out there to all of you.
So get some of that.
And then also a youtube,
we have a youtube channel if you want to check that out.
It's,
it's starring echos videos.
It's starring the video version of this podcast.
This right.
Well who made that well?
Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
So it's starting Echo Charles his videos.
So check out that you can see what Jason Gardner looks like.
Yeah,
that's something you're going to,
you're going to definitely want to see what Jason Gardener it looks like.
Does,
do you think Jason does?
And people please let me know.
Does Jason Gardner look how he sounds?
I think so.
Yeah.
You think so?
Well the thing is I've,
I you already saw,
I saw you and didn't hear you.
A lot of people in this room.
Yeah.
Pizza's going to be,
I think you probably,
I think you probably look how you sound,
I think.
I think,
but it's hard for me to make that judgment because I know you,
I,
I kinda,
I got to find that picture.
I'll post a picture of you and me age,
whatever,
2019 yeah.
And,
and we want to go completely insane.
You guys went in at the same time?
No,
he went in a few years before,
years before.
And then we ran over and do each other overseas and just really hit it off.
Uh,
what else?
Psychological warfare.
Yes.
What that is.
I used to go into this LDP,
he'd get mad every time that that probably is the one that broke me.
This is the one that I was like,
Bro,
we're not doing this whole support thing anymore.
We're done doing it.
We're done.
I'm not doing anymore.
I'm not going to listen to you.
It's not happening.
But I was going to go Joe Rogan's downs to recorded afterwards by myself
somewhere.
Well,
you can just be cool.
Why yet?
The roof is going to be in the pudding.
Jason Garden again,
what psychological refers.
Oh actually,
you know what?
It's not because Jason Gardens in the game deep in the game.
So for him to know what psychological warfare is,
isn't a big stress is not going to be very surprising.
Yes.
So for the,
for the people who don't know what it is,
this is what it is.
It's an album with tracks,
chocolate check.
The thing you got to remember about this,
this whole segment of us just sitting around and talking for the quote unquote
supports,
which at barely is right.
It's more just like
just a session of,
but it was because when we got done with some podcasts early on,
it was like being drug through like the emotional freaking hell yeah,
and you get done and you want to just go home.
Like do you want to just like,
okay,
let's,
it's like my,
my youngest daughter,
she'll,
if she sees something scary or whatever or you know,
she'll say like,
can we watch something funny just,
and so that's what this actually is,
is hey,
okay,
we're going to talk about people getting killed,
people getting blown up,
people getting butchered,
real people,
by the way.
And when we get done with that,
we're going to lighten it up a little bit so we can carry on.
We're not going to forget about it,
but we're going to have a little bit of levity towards the end.
That's what this originally was.
Somehow you ended up just saying the same thing over and over again with that
one to take about tacos.
Getting good at saying it.
You see what I'm saying?
So yeah.
So what I did was I did lose sight of some things,
but we're back and you know,
I'm going to explain what psychologic warfare,
but people don't know.
It's an album with tracks.
Jacqueline tracks talking about how you can overcome certain moments of weakness
on the path.
Boom.
That's pretty concise.
Yeah.
Cool.
Next on it on it.com case on it.
Good company.
This is where I get kettle bells home.
Gym,
Home Gym
Jim,
yet?
No,
I just moved.
Oh yeah,
you don't have one right now.
Just got the rings,
the rings boom.
That's the,
that's the original thing that you need to get right.
The first thing you need to get.
I didn't use to think that.
I used to think it was a pull up bar,
but I changed my mind.
Yeah.
Cause more versatility.
Cause rings or a pull up bar.
Rent guests.
They are and they're,
and they're also a dip bar and they're also a a ring pushup bar to thing.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
It's a thing.
I got my earnings from on it anyway.
[inaudible] dot com you can get kettle bells rings.
What battle ropes.
Those Macy's,
those crazy do workout with that man.
You'd be,
you'd be in the game big time.
Anyway.
A lot of good stuff on there.
I go there.
[inaudible] dot com slash Jocko cause we got some books too.
Um,
we got some books like Mikey and the dragons,
which you know,
I think might be the best kid's book ever written.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
I Dunno,
I read this other one knows quite a warrior King Mike and the dragons.
Check it out.
It is going to help kids overcome fear and it's an entertaining story and it's
got awesome drawings in it
and it ramps.
Yeah.
I just shipped one out to my buddy on the east coast and he's got little ones
and he hit me up yesterday on text.
He goes,
you know,
bro,
I just read that to my kids because I'm three hours ahead of us.
They loved it.
That book is awesome.
Thank you.
I have people that,
this is odd,
but I have people that,
I have people that say I get a got a tears in my eyes when I was reading the
letter to his son.
You know,
that can be kind of heavy.
So when I made that original short video about it,
whatever.
Yeah,
I should,
I think I said this story,
I showed it to my brother and he's like,
he's like,
man,
I'm kind of like tearing up.
I don't know why.
Then we're watching the video and it's not like it's a super sad thing,
but it just,
it's like,
I guess it's like so like real,
you know,
like these are things you kind of got to deal with and they get to take on this
courage kind of thing and it's like,
I don't know.
It was weird.
Yeah.
So check out that,
check out the warrior kid books where way the warrior kid and Mikey or and
Mark's mission.
Somebody asked me,
people sometimes ask questions that center around themselves.
They're asking you a question,
but somebody asked me a question.
It said two words.
What is the theme of way of the warrior kid go into words that that was the
question.
So,
so,
so now this person just wanted me to say like sum up this book in two words and
this was a mandate.
It wasn't like,
hey man,
could you kind of give you a fish?
It was like two words.
So I was like,
cool.
You know what I said?
It's really,
it's actually really easy.
What is the underlying theme of the way of the Warrior kid book series?
The underlying theme is this where your kid,
there you go.
It's like you want your kids to be warriors.
What does that mean?
Does that mean you want them to join the military and and go fight?
No.
I mean,
do you want to be warriors whole thing,
which actually gets explained in there,
man,
that's the warrior kid books,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
You,
I've signed a lot of those for your people.
Yeah.
I bought like 10 of them and had you sign them to a bunch of guys and send them
out.
They love him and help people out.
Yeah.
I've had guys
in the last year lose somebody,
like have someone in a family or friend die and then I'm like,
okay,
go look at this page,
you know?
Yup.
Where are you?
Describe how to deal with it.
Yeah.
I actually had to use that page myself and
hopefully you don't have to use that page,
but there's other things that go on in your life that can steer you off the path
and there's other pages of that book that will keep you on the path.
This because freedom field,
manual,
extreme ownership,
everything.
Jason was talking about what we did at Trey debt.
Everything that we tried to teach to the seals that were going to go overseas.
It's in the book extreme ownership.
It's in the book.
The dichotomy of leadership.
They're both in.
There you are.
Show me your notes the other day,
Jason,
from,
from when I in briefed your troop,
it's like,
oh,
here's your notes.
You gave him me little picture.
What did they say?
They say covering move,
simple,
prioritize and execute and decentralized command.
That was why,
I dunno,
12 years ago or something like that.
10 years ago,
same words coming out to see him.
Word hasn't changed.
Learn those
extreme ownership and the dichotomy.
Leadership national on front,
that is our leadership consultancy where we solve problems through leadership
and every organization has problems,
all kinds of problems,
all kinds of problems and every single one of those problems is a leadership
problem.
That's what's going to fix it is fixing the leadership.
That's what we do.
It's me.
It's late,
Bab and JP to know Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike Cirelli,
Mike by Emma
and
does this make you a new guy?
You're a new guy.
That's why frog bro and our latest member,
I won't call them a new guy because it really does matter.
You went to bud's before me,
right?
So that's like a real thing.
Like I'm a new guy.
Yeah.
Apparently
not ever say.
Yeah.
Anyways,
our latest,
um,
Jason Gardner who you've just listened to for five hours is also on the team and
if you want help with your organization and your leadership inside your
organization,
go national in front.com
okay.
Also we have to muster
the monster is a leadership conference gathering magical,
magical.
It actually actually it's just muster and it is a monster.
That's what it is,
right?
We're all gonna get together.
We'll talk about leadership,
get granular and delve into leadership from a lot of different angles.
May 23rd and 24th in Chicago,
September 19th and 20th and Denver,
December 4th and fifth and Sydney extreme ownership.com.
I haven't posted about this yet.
Just the muster in,
I haven't posted at all when I post.
It's a lot of stuff.
It's cells,
so if you want to go,
awesome.
Same is if you want to go register now,
Code Echelon front.com actually go to extreme ownership.com and that's where you
can register to come to the muster in one of those locations.
We will see you there.
Eif,
online,
interactive leadership training,
starting to see the cool feedback from people on that.
So e f online.
It is [inaudible] dot com we have leadership training courses online,
interactive.
What else?
What other verbs or adjectives to describe interactive,
engaging in very engaging,
what name your adventure.
Choose your own adventure,
choose your own adventure kind of scenarios.
The unfold and we're updating it and adding different content to it monthly.
So it's going to continue to grow and educate both you and us as we all learn to
become better leaders if you want.
In on that,
I went through that obviously to make the video and coincidentally few like a
month,
maybe month and a half before I went through an online training for CPR.
Okay.
So the online training for CPR,
well,
CPR,
you got to do the physical thing too,
you know,
for the certification,
whatever.
But there's an online training part of it,
so you know,
and not too bad,
not too bad.
The online thing,
you know,
I really went through it,
kind of committed myself to it,
not as long or whatever,
but you know,
kind of,
I went through,
I was like,
cool,
good.
But there were tangible things that have been,
you know,
you could've done this a little bit more different to actual actually get the
training,
quote unquote training that someone might need,
whatever.
So,
you know,
a few months later I do
go through the eff online and I'm thinking to myself,
when I think back on those CPR,
this is what they should of did with the CPR thing.
Granted the CPR,
he could tell us a lot older.
It wasn't quite as contemporary.
So I'm not really blaming them,
but that's the way I really saw it.
I was like,
okay,
this is good.
This will give you like the training training,
you know,
it'll,
it'll allow you to make mistakes.
On an online training or do the wrong thing and then get corrected as a,
hey you did this,
you know kind of,
well that's one of the things that worried me.
But cause you remember the navy like navy course,
you take on something that was online and it will be horrible and boring and
everyone just copy each other and just click through the things to get it done
when you don't take anything away from it.
That was my fear or how does this,
if we,
if we don't do this right,
but then as soon as I started looking at the technology and the things you could
do and the way you could make engaging,
it's,
I don't want to say it's better,
but if you're sitting in or if you're sitting at the muster and I say something
and you're like,
wow,
when you go to write that down and then you hear me say this tail end of
something else and you missed it,
you can't press rewind,
rewatch it.
You can't press pause and be like,
that was a really good point.
I know how I can apply that to my world and just write down how to handle
something.
You can't do that at the muster on online.
Oh,
let me rewatch that.
oh,
Jocko and Leif just did a role play on dealing with uh,
uh,
someone in the office.
I actually need to deal with a person like that.
How should I,
how should I tell him to watch that again and to see those little maneuvers take
place.
So that's what we did and we realized that we just don't have the reach for the
demand that's out there for echelon front.
We appreciate the demand and we want to satisfy the demand.
So that is f online.com if you want to get fully engaged in our leadership
training,
that's it.
And of course we have EIF,
Overwatch,
where we're taking all these experienced leaders that have been in combat for
the last couple decades.
And as they move into the civilian sector,
placing them into jobs where they can help lead organizations using the
experience they have and their understanding of the principles that we talk
about@echelonfrontinthebookextremeownershipandonthispodcastgotoefoverwatch.com
where they're standing by waiting for you.
By the way,
Andy,
if you
got done or get done listening to this three hours of conversation and you want
to continue it further,
it's it wasn't enough and you're not sure what to do,
well then that's cool because you can actually get in touch with us and have a
little calmer,
a little mini micro conversations with us
on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on that shaft.
Half-Asian we'll keep,
we'll half echoes adequate.
Charles,
I am at at Jocko Willink and Jason has multiple handles.
Go Jason and Gardner on Twitter,
Jason.
Dot.
N.
Gardner on Instagram and Jason and Gardner on Facebook.
You're going to have fun with Twitter.
I'm just going to let you know because Twitter is the place for somebody with
little one liners to hang out and participate and throw one lighters out into
the world and make people laugh or make people think and it's just,
it's,
it's pretty fun.
It's member.
You ever feel like the Terminator robot,
you don't feel like that?
No,
I do.
And one of the ways that I feel that is when I'm having a conversation with
someone and I see little one liners of what I can say and sometimes,
I mean if I'm answering questions for a client,
I'll be like,
okay,
here's like,
as soon as they're asking me,
I'm seeing little possible answers of how they fit in their world and does it
make sense to them.
And I've got all this and then I just kind of choose one to go and when I'm
having,
but I remember that in like when I was a school child,
I was a little kid going to school,
especially like around what grade is fifth,
sixth and seventh grade.
How old are you?
Not Fourth is 11 like 11 1213 right?
Yeah.
Saturday.
It was like every single comment or statement that it's school teacher made was
just a prime setup to knock it out of the park with a one liner from the back
row.
You know what I'm saying?
I would just be sitting there going,
oh Aye.
I,
I would want,
I would be so Tim and I have to bite my tongue all day long,
as much as I could.
Because when you're 12 years old,
you can only hold it in for so long.
It'd be four.
It just comes out and then,
so anyways,
you're going to like Twitter because you can use your little one liners,
which you are very,
very good at and they're always,
like I said,
they're always very educational or humorous or they at least make you think so
you'll have fun with that and don't feed the trolls and don't feed the Russian
bots.
No,
that's my new thing.
Be careful.
Don't click on anything.
Check.
All right.
Echo,
anything else?
No.
Awesome.
Jason?
Yeah,
I'd like to thank my parents,
Jim and cookie Gardner for all your unconditional love and support.
Over the years.
My sister Ari,
who's a blue belt into Jujitsu.
How'd you did?
You did sir.
What,
how'd you get into the podcast?
Listen to the podcast immediately.
Found a Jujitsu place up there and San Clemente and started training.
And then um,
my brother thought he as soon as a tattoo artist tattoos up in San Clemente at
San Clemente Tattoo.
If you're going to get some ink,
go see him if you're local and thanks to everybody else and thanks to all the
frog men out there past,
present and future.
Get some
hell yeah.
And we always think everyone in uniform that protects us at home and abroad from
the evil that we talked about today.
And that includes obviously our military personnel,
police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT is correctional officer's border patrol,
all the first responders.
And also thanks to all of those that did serve
and that have done their part as veterans for our great nation.
Like my brother here,
master chief Jason Gardner.
Thanks for your service.
Thanks for coming on.
And of course I'm looking forward to another bunch of good years together.
Thanks for everything Bra.
And to everyone else that's listening.
Okay,
I'll go back to Beowulf.
For every one of us living in this world means waiting for an end.
Let whoever can win glory before death.
So endurer your troubles today.
Bear up and be the man I expect you to be.
That's how our ancestors lived,
and that's how they died.
So let us do the same.
Arise,
set forth,
okay.
And get after it.
Okay.
And until next time,
this is Jason Gardner and Deco and Jocko out.